NOW THE IDEAS COMING IN I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- APPRECIATE THAT
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC LEVINE AND
I WOULD LIKE TO CALL THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
FOOD SYSTEMS TO ORDER WELL THE
ASSEMBLY IS LIFTED ITS COVERT
NINETEEN PROTOCOLS MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDING TODAY HERE
TODAY'S HEARING ARE ENCOURAGED
TO WEAR A MASK INTO OBSERVE
APPROPRIATE SOCIAL DISTANCING IF
FIVE APPROPRIATE- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC NOT LISTED ON THE AGENDA
ARE WELCOME TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF TODAY'S
HEARING HERE IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. IF A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IS NOT ABLE TO ATTEND TODAY'S
HEARING THE COMMITTEES- THE
COMMITTEE WELCOMES WRITTEN
TESTIMONY WHICH CAN BE EMAILED
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOT LEVINE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV THAT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOT LEVINE
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. I WOULD
ALSO ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
CONNECT WITH US ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AT ASM MARC LEVINE TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION TO STAY
CONNECTED ON IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE ISSUES. FEW ISSUES
HAVE UNIVERSALLY IMPACTED
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
JUST THE PAST YEAR LIKE THE
INFLATIONARY IMPACT ON FOOD
PRICES ACCORDING TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR HOUSEHOLD
GROCERY BILLS SWELLED BY EIGHT
POINT 6% IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS THE LARGEST JUMP SINCE
APRIL NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. FOOD
AT HOME PRICES ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE BETWEEN 3% AND 4% BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ACCORDING TO A RECENT US
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
FORECAST WAGES ARE NOT ABLE TO
KEEP PACE WITH THE INCREASED
COST OF NECESSITIES AND FOOD
ACCESS ORGANIZATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO ADDRESS. INCREASED
DEMAND THAT BEGAN DURING THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ACCORDING TO AN APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ARTICLE BY CNBC THE
COST OF MEAT POULTRY FISH AND
EGGS IS 13% HIGHER SINCE
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FRESH FRUIT HAS GONE UP TEN
POINT 6% IN PRICE IN THAT TIME
WHILE THE PRICE FOR VEGETABLES
HAS REMAINED MORE STABLE
INCREASING JUST FOUR POINT THREE
PERCENT. THE PRICE OF PRE
PACKAGED CEREALS AND BAKED GOODS
HAS INCREASED SEVEN POINT 7%
THIS IS NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR MANY
FAMILIES. ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
FEELING THE PINCH AND FAMILIES
THAT RELY ON FOOD ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT FROM FOOD BANKS ARE
SPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO THESE
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN EVERYDAY
FOOD COSTS. THE UNITED STATES
FOOD SYSTEM IS A COMPLEX WEB OF
PRODUCTION PROCESSING TRANSPORT
AND CONSUMPTION. EACH SEGMENT OF
OUR FOOD SYSTEM HAS BEEN
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY INFLATION
MAKING THIS PERIOD OF TIME
DIFFICULT FOR FOOD GROWERS FOOD
PRODUCERS WORKERS IN THE FOOD
AND LOGISTICS INDUSTRIES AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER. TODAY'S HEARING IS
PART OF A BROADER DISCUSSION
ABOUT ADDRESSING FOOD
INSECURITY. PROMOTING EQUITABLE
FOOD ACCESS AND ADDRESSING THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM IMPACTS OF
INFLATION ON CALIFORNIA FOOD
SYSTEMS. I WANT TO THANK TODAY'S
PANELISTS FOR PARTICIPATING THIS
HEARING AND ACCEPTING THE
INVITATION TO JOIN US. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
AFTERNOON. I WANT TO THANK GOD.
ALSO THE STAFF IN THE AUDIO
VIDEO- TEAM- FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THIS IS RUNNING AWAY THAT
EVERYONE CAN HAVE ACCESS TO IT.
AT THIS TIME- I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE FIRST PANEL AND
THE FIRST PANEL IS A PANEL ONE
IS WHY IS INFLATION HAPPENING
NOW AND WHAT ARE ITS IMPACTS ON
FOOD SYSTEMS. OUR FIRST PANELIST
WELL MENTION BOTH OF THEM DR
JERRY NICHOLS BURKE FROM UCLA
SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT ANDERSON
SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT AND DR
DANIELS DANIEL SUMNER UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF AGRICULTURE. DR
NICHOLS BURKE YOU ARE UP FIRST
IN YOUR JOINING US VIRTUALLY. DR
NICK SO WE SEE YOU NOW. BUT WE
DON'T HEAR YOU YET. WHAT CAN WE
GET WE GOT A- DO A COUPLE THINGS
I THINK STILL GET YOUR AUDIO. I
THINK YOU'RE GOOD NOW. NO BUT
THERE. FOR THE FOLKS YOU AT HOME
WE DID DO AN AUDIO TRACK AND
THINGS WORKED EARLIER AS A THANK
YOU DOCTOR ISN'T NIKOLSBURG FOR
HELPING US- PREPARE AND- AND
WE'RE WORKING ON IT. YOU KNOW
WHAT. YOU ARE NOW GOOD TO GO.
THAT WAS THAT WAS ME BY THE WAY
. OKAY SO THIS IS GOOD NOW RIGHT
ABSOLUTELY. OKAY- WELL FIRST OF
ALL- LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT INFLATION IN CALIFORNIA
YEAH AND TO MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS PANEL- GOING TO DRILL DOWN
ON SOME OF THE GEOGRAPHICAL AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT
WOULD I'D LIKE TO FOCUS MY
REMARKS ON- WHO IS THE
MACROECONOMIC SETTING OF
INFLATION AND WHERE WE THINK.
IT'S GOING AND WHY. IT AS IT
TURNS OUT JUST TO START WITH
SOME DEFINITIONS THE INFLATION
IN GENERAL IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
MEASURE. THAT IS IN THE ECONOMIC
DEFINITION IS OUR RIGHTS AND ALL
PRICES. OVER ALL PRICES OF
COURSE ARE NOT EQUAL A 20%
INCREASE IN THE PRICE FOR A JAR
OF PAPRIKA IS NOT THE SAME IN
TERMS OF THE ECONOMIC AND
WELFARE IMPACT OF THE 20%
INCREASE. IN THE PRICE OF A
GALLON OF GASOLINE. THE US
BUREAU CENSUS FINANCES THIS
ISSUE BY USING A WEIGHTED SAMPLE
OF PRICES WITH THE WEIGHTS FOR
FROM THE THREE YEAR SURVEY OF
URBAN CONSUMER BUYING HABITS.
FROM THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES
OF COURSE OUR BUYING HABITS ARE
DIFFERENT TODAY BUT TO HAVE A
CONSISTENT MEASURE THE WEIGHTS
CHANGE PRINCIPALLY TO REFLECT
THE QUALITY AND TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES OVER TIME. NOT THE
CHANGES IN OUR TASTES AND
PREFERENCES SO THAT'S A WAY OF
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THESE INFLATION NUMBERS.
WITH THE- BIT OF SKEPTICISM
ABOUT THE OVERALL HEADLINE
NUMBERS AND DIG DOWN DEEPER. FOR
THE U. S. THE AVERAGE RATE OF
INFLATION AS MEASURED BY THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX FOR ALL
CONSUMERS. OVER THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS WAS EIGHT POINT THREE
PERCENT. I BUT IT'S DIFFERENT AS
WE MOVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR
LOS ANGELES MSA WHICH INCLUDES
ORANGE COUNTY WAS SEVEN POINT
NINE PERCENT. FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO MSA WHICH INCLUDES THE
EAST BAY IT WAS ONLY FIVE
PERCENT. AND MUCH OF THIS
DIFFERENCE IS DUE TO THE IMPACT
OF CHANGES IN SHELTER COSTS AND
HOW THEY ENTER THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX. SHELTERS
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF THE
CPI. AND IT IS A MEASUREMENT
MEASURED AS AN AVERAGE OF RENTS
PAID BY RENTERS. AND OWNERS OF
QUICKLY WRAP WHICH IS NOT PAID
BY HOMEOWNERS. AND IS ABOUT 55%
OF ALL CAT CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. IT IS THE RENT THAT
THEY WOULD PAY THEY. WERE
RENTING THEIR HOME RATHER THAN
BUYING IT. SO IN FACT THE C.
THAT OVER. AHEAD NUMBER IS MY
MORE REP. OF THE IMPACT OF PRICE
INCREASES. ON THE APPROXIMATE
ONE HALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
RENT. IN THESE ARE OF COURSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LESS AFFLUENT
HOUSEHOLDS. THE BIG DRIVERS OF
INFLATION IN THE US TODAY OUR
AUTOMOBILES ENERGY FOOD AIRPLANE
FLIGHTS AND SHELTER. ORDER
PRICES SHOULD DECLINE AS A
SHORTAGE OF CHIPS EASES AND WHAT
THAT WILL TAKE TIME THE TREND IS
CLEAR. ENERGY PRICES HAVE
STABILIZED ALBEIT AT A HIGH
LEVEL BUT THEIR IMPACT THROUGH
THE ECONOMY IS STILL BEING FELT
IMPORTANT IS THE ROLE OF WHAT
THAT OIL PRICES HAVE IN THE
PRODUCTION OF FOOD BUT DIRECTLY
EMPOWERING FARM EQUIPMENT AND
TRUCKING. AND THROUGH THEIR INFO
IMPORTANCIA FERTILIZER HIGH
ENERGY PRICES ARE NOT EXPECTED
TO DECLINE AS THE WAR RAGES ON
IN THE UKRAINE. AND THE ABILITY
OF PRODUCERS ELSEWHERE TO RAMP
UP PRODUCTION BEING DEPENDENT ON
INVESTMENT IN DRILLING RIGS. I
NEVER THE LESS FURTHER INCREASES
ARE NOT EXPECTED. AND SO THAT'S
THE GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS WILL
GROWTH GOING TO HAVE HIGHER OIL
PRICES HIGHER FERTILIZER PRICES
FOR SOME TIME BUT NOT INCREASING
IN ANY SIGNIFICANT WAY OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS. AIRPLANE
FLIGHTS REPRESENT OF RECOVERY
FROM VERY LOW RATES AND THEY ARE
THEMSELVES NOT EXPECTED TO
INCREASE AT THE SAME RATE GOING
FORWARD AND SHELTER COST
INCREASES HAVE OUTSTIPPED THE
INCREASE IN HOUSEHOLD INCOMES
AND WHILE THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
DUE TO DEMOGRAPHICS. AND POST
CODE THE CHANGE HOUSEHOLD
PREFERENCES FOR MORE SPACE THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD INFLATION
RATES HIGH OVER THE COMING YEAR.
ABOUT ONE OF THE LARGEST DRIVERS
OF INFLATION TODAY AS WITH
POINTED OUT IN THE INTRODUCTION
IS FOOD AND A BIG PART OF THIS
STEMS FROM THE PRODUCTION OF
WHEAT. NOT ONLY OUR PRODUCTION
COSTS HIGHER DUE TO THE INCREASE
IN THE PRICE OF OIL BUT THE
SUPPLY IS BEEN SERIOUSLY
CURTAILED. THE LARGEST WORLD
WHEAT PRODUCERS IN THE WORLD ARE
THE US RUSSIA INDIA AND CHINA IN
THE US AND ELSEWHERE PRODUCTION
IS DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE U.
S. ABOUT 8% LITTLE MORE THAN 8%
DUE TO DROUGHT. CHINA DOES NOT
PRODUCE AND FOR ITS NEEDS IN PUT
AT THE ON X. AND THE WHEAT
PRODUCING REGION IN INDIA
SUFFERING FROM EXTREME HEAT. AND
THE RUSSIAN SUPPLIES NOW BEEN
CUT OFF. THIS WILL INDUCE A
SUBSTITUTION TO OTHER GRAINS
SUCH AS CORN AND RICE AND THEIR
PRICES WILL THEN INCREASE. IN
ADDITION TO THE HIGH PRICE OF
GASOLINE A SHIFT- THERE'S A
SHIFT IN IN DEMAND TO ETHANOL
WHICH WILL ALSO INCREASE THE
DEMAND. AND THE PRICE OF CORN.
THAT BECAUSE- CALIFORNIA'S LARGE
AGRICULTURAL HE BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. GOOD PRICE INFLATION
IS LIGHTLY LIKELY TO BE SLIGHTLY
LOWER. IN TERMS OF THE RATE OF
INCREASE. THEN THE US GOING
FORWARD BUT NOT BY MUCH. MORE
OVER THE SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE NOT SUBSTANTIALLY
RECOVERED FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY
RECESSION. BY THE SERVICE
SECTORS WITH THE AVERAGE INCOME
OF THOSE EMPLOYED IS LOWER THAN
THE MEDIAN INCOME IN CALIFORNIA.
N. THERE IS A MUCH GREATER
NUMBER OF PREVIOUSLY EMPLOYED
OUT OF WORK ON AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS SPEND ABOUT 13% A
LITTLE MORE THAN 13% OF THEIR
INCOME ON FOOD. UP WITH ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THAT THE INQUEST
REPURCHASES LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WILL SPEND AT LEAST
DOUBLE THAT PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
INCOME. IN THESE ARE THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE FACING THE
MORE DIFFICULT EMPLOYMENT
MARKETS AND THEY ARE CLEARLY THE
MOST IMPACTED BY THE CURRENT.
AND WHAT WE EXPECT TO BE THE
INCREASING COST OF GOING
FORWARD. AND WITH THAT I WILL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
NIKOLSBURG- NOT SURE IF WE HAVE
DOCTOR SUMNER HERE. YEAH VIDEO
GREAT I THANK YOU. AND PLEASE
STICK AROUND FOR SOME Q. AND A
ON FOR THE PANEL. DR SUMMER. YES
ABOUT MY AUDIO WE ARE HERE YOU
FIND WE DON'T SEE A HERE WE SEE
YOU NOW. NICE HOUSE. THANK YOU.
SEEM LIKE THE RIGHT BACKGROUND
FOR THIS MEETING WELL GET
STARTED IT AND ASSUME YOU'LL GET
THE VIDEO UP EUROPE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. AND I'M GONNA USE THE
FEW MINUTES AVAILABLE TO MAKE UP
A FEW VERY BRIEF POINTS ABOUT
THE CURRENT BOUT OF INFLATION IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AS WE'VE
WE'VE JUST HEARD INFLATION IS
THE WIDESPREAD CONTINUED RATE OF
INCREASE IN OF THE GENERAL LEVEL
OF PRICES OF GOODS AND SERVICES
IN THE ECONOMY. ALL SPECIFIC
FARM PRICES ALL SUCH AS FOR
EXAMPLE ALMONDS AND ALFALFA TO
TAKE TO IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
CROPS A JUMP UP AND DOWN FROM
MONTH TO MONTH AND FROM YEAR TO
YEAR. OFFER COMMODITY SPECIFIC
REASONS- LIKE US SUPPLY SHOCK
BAD WEATHER. OR FOR THAT MATTER
GREAT WEATHER PRICES GO UP AND
DOWN. ALL BUT THIS FLUX. IN
RELATIVE PRICES ISN'T INFLATION
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHAT PRICES ARE DOWN. DUE TO
LOW OF LESS WORLD DEMAND FOR
COMPLICATED REASONS OF BLOOD
EIGHT PRICES ARE ARE UP A LOT
AND THAT'S DUE TO AN OUTBREAK OF
AVIAN INFLUENZA AGAIN NEITHER
ONE OF THOSE ARE REALLY
INFLATION- DEFINED AS WE THINK
ABOUT INFLATION. AND IN
PARTICULAR OF THE FED FOR
EXAMPLE ATTENDS TO DISCOUNT OF
FOOD PRICES IT WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT INFLATION THEIR PREFERRED
MEASURE TO TALK ABOUT INFLATION
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
IDIOSYNCRATIC FLUX IN IN FARM
PRICES AND FARM COMMODITY PRICES
IN THE FOODS MOST TIED. CLOSELY
TIED TO THEM. I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT FOOD PRICES. THAT YOU AND I
BY IN THE RETAIL STORE ARE
MOSTLY COMPRISED OF LABOR AND
REAL ESTATE AND ALL THE COSTS
THAT GO INTO MARKETING. AND OF
THE FARM PRICES OR FOR EXAMPLE A
RELATIVELY SMALL PART OF THAT.
ABOUT 50% FOR MILK WHICH OF FOR
FLUID MILK WHICH GOES PRETTY
MUCH DIRECTLY TO THE SUPERMARKET
WITH VERY LITTLE PROCESSING.
WHAT WE HEARD A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE PRICE OF WHEAT. AND MOST OF
US EAT OUR WAY WE CAN THE FORMAL
PASTA OR BREAD OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. AND THE FARM PRICE A WEEK
IS BETWEEN FIVE AND 10% OF THE
RETAIL PRICES OF THE GOODS THAT
HAVE WHEAT IN THEM. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING TO REMEMBER WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
FARM AND WHAT THAT MEANS OF FOR
RETAIL PRICES FOR ALL OF US. BOB
THE COST OF INPUTS FOR
CALIFORNIA FARMS AND RANCHES
HAVE BEEN RISING BECAUSE OF THE
ENGINE IN GENERAL INFLATION
RATE. AND BECAUSE OF THESE
IDIOSYNCRATIC ONE TIME REASONS.
IN THESE HIGHER COSTS SQUEEZE
THE BOTTOM LINE IN FOR SUPPLY
ADJUSTMENTS. I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT A FEW OF THOSE A LITTLE
BIT LATER BUT LET ME MENTION
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN IN THE
NEWS A LOT AND THAT IS. ALL HIGH
PRICE OF FERTILIZERS. THEY'RE
TIED TO NATURAL GAS THEY'RE ALSO
TIED. UP ALL THE IMPORTS AND
EXPORTS. BUT WHAT ABOUT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT FERTILIZER PRICES WE
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE DAY BEGAN
RISING AFTER YEARS OF FAIRLY
STABLE OF PRICES THEY BEGAN
RISING IN MID TWENTY TWENTY. AND
WENT AND DOUBLED BY THE TIME WE
GOT TO THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. ARE THEY RISEN 15% THIS
YEAR ALL OF WHICH OCCURRED.
AFTER THE MIDDLE OF MARCH SO
THAT IS WE HAD BLACK FERTILIZER
PRICES AT HIGH LEVELS. BUT THEN
THEY TOOK OFF WELL AT THE TIME
OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION OF
UKRAINE. AND THEN THEY'VE
THEY'VE ACTUALLY STABILIZE THE
LAST FEW WEEKS SO THEY HAVEN'T
CONTINUE TO RISE THERE WAS A BIG
ZOOM. AND THEN OF FLAT AGAIN IN
MOST. PROJECTIONS FOR WHAT
THEY'RE WORTH ALL ARE SUGGESTING
THAT FERTILIZER PRICES ALL ARE
LIKELY TO BE STABLE NOT COME
DOWN BUT BE STABLE IN MY
COLLEAGUE AARON SMITH. HAS
ANALYZED- THOSE FERTILIZER
PRICES IN SOME DETAIL. THE THIRD
THING I WANT TO MENTION IS THAT
ARM. AS FARMERS BY THE FULL
RANGE OF GOODS AND SERVICES FROM
THE ECONOMY EVERYTHING. UP FROM
FROM FARM LABOR TO SERVICES
ACCOUNTING SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE
INFLATION IN THE GENERAL ECONOMY
AFFECTS COSTS ON FARMS I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE THE PRICE OF
HOUSING IN L. A. GOES UP AND WE
JUST HEARD HOUSING IS A BIG PART
OF THE INFLATION RATE FOR
CONSUMERS. WHAT IS THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH FARMS- WORKERS OF
COMPETE FOR HIGHER WAGES IF AN
ACCOUNTING FIRM WANTS TO KEEP
ITS WORKERS IT PAYS MORE. THE
COST OF ACCOUNTING SERVICES TO A
FARM OF THEN GOES UP AND SO
THESE THINGS ARE VERY CLOSELY
CONNECTED AND WHAT YOU THINK IS
TWO OR THREE STEPS AWAY FROM THE
FARM WILL AFFECT FORM COSTS. AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT. BOB THERE ARE
ALSO FAR- SPECIFIC- OF FORM
FACTORS THAT AFFECT NDIVIDUAL
MARKETS FOR EXAMPLE I MENTIONED
WALNUT FARMS WILL BE HARD HIT BY
INFLATION BUT THEY'RE ASO
FACING DROUGHT THEY'RE ALSO
FACING PORT PROBLEMS FOR THEIR
EXPORTS BECAUSE THE BACK CALL
ISSUE OF SHIPPING CONTAINERS AND
ALL THEY'VE BEEN FACING MORE
COMPETITION IN GROUP GROWING
MARKETS SO THERE'S NO REASON TO
THINK WALMART PRICES ARE GOING
TO BE MUCH HIGHER IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT'S A REALLY
SERIOUS PROBLEM BECAUSE THEIR
COSTS ARE GOING UP BECAUSE THE
INFLATION. AND THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR CERTAIN INDUSTRIES
LET ME TAKE THE LAST COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT HIRED FARM
WORKERS BECAUSE THERE ARE A
CRUCIAL AND CENTRAL PART OF
AGRICULTURE. LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS. THEY ARE
AMONG THE MOST LOW WAGE AND
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
. ALL THEIR WROTE WAGES ARE
RISING BUT IT'S HARD FOR THOSE
WAGES TO KEEP UP FOR WITH
INFLATION LET ME JUST GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE SO YOU HAVE WORKERS
ON A FARM IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA. THAT HAS- THE
WAGE RATE GOES FRM TWENTY BUCKS
AN HOUR TO TWENTY ONE FIFTY THIS
SUMMER. THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
KEEP UP WITH INFLATION FOR THOSE
WORKERS. IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO KEEP
UP WITH THEIR FOOD PRICE
INFLATION. FURTHERMORE FOR THOSE
WORKERS THE DROUGHT IS GOING TO
MEAN LESS WORK AVAILABLE. STILL
HIGHER WAGES ARE GONNA LEAVE
THOSE PEOPLE EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE THAN THEY STARTED.
AND THIS IS TYPICAL FOR
INFLATION THAT SOME PEOPLE WERE
HURT WORSE THAN OTHERS- SOME
PEOPLE CAN HAVE PRICED THEIR OWN
WAGES OF THEIR PRICES THE KEEP
UP. UP THIS UNCERTAINTY THIS
IMBEDDED WITHIN THEM INFLATION
IS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
THERE'S ALSO UNCERTAINTY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE- WINDING
DOWN OF INFLATION AND THAT
ESPECIALLY HAS TO DO WITH
INTEREST RATES. AND THEN WE CAN
TALK LATER IF YOU'D LIKE ABOUT
THE SEVERE PROBLEMS WE HAD IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE BUT LET
ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING. AS
INTEREST RATES ARE RISING NOW WE
A RECOGNIZE HOW CAPITAL
INTENSIVE AGRICULTURE IS WHETHER
IT'S ALL. THE STATUTE TREES THAT
LAST FORTY OR FIFTY YEARS MAJOR
CAPITAL INVESTMENT LONG TIME PAY
OFF. FARMS BOROUGH MONEY AT. IN
THE OVER THE LAST TEN OR FIFTEEN
YEARS VERY LOW INTEREST RATES.
EASIER TO PAY THAT BACK OVER THE
LONG HAUL. NOW WE SEE RISING
INTEREST RATES MUCH HIGHER
INTEREST COSTS IN THE ONLY MAKES
SENSE IF YOU THINK THE OUTPUT
PRICES ARE GONNA STAY HIGHER
GOAL HIGHER WITH INFLATION. THAT
IS TO SAY TO BE ABLE TO PAY OFF
THE LOAN WITH INFLATED DOLLARS
OF FORM AS TO BE COMFORTABLE
AND CONFIDENT THAT THESE PRICES
ARE CONTINUE TO GO UP. THIS
NAVIGATING THE WINDING DOWN OF
INFLATION. THEN RAISES EVEN MORE
CONCERNS OR AT LEAST EQUAL
CONCERNS AND HAS ITS OWN
PROBLEMS AND I THINK AS WE HAVE
THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND OTHERS.
BEGINNING TO UNRAVEL INFLATION
AND INTEREST RATES ARE GOING UP
WELL THAT'S A WHOLE SET OF
CHALLENGES WE ALL OUGHT TO KEEP
OUR EYE ON. IT LET ME STOP THERE
. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PROFESSOR THAT WAS KIND OF A I
OPENING JOLT TO SUGGEST THAT.
OUR ATTEMPTS TO CONTROL
INFLATION WILL END UP- WILL HAVE
A SEND UP WITH RISING COSTS FOR
FOOD- LONGER LONGER TERM IN THE
OUT YEARS BECAUSE OF- THIS
INCREASED RATES. SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT LET'S- LET'S GO BACK TO
BOTH OF YOU TOUCHED ON INFLATION
OBVIOUSLY- SINCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS BUT- WHAT WE WANT TO.
DEAL WITH IN AND DOCUMENT
NIKOLSBURG I WANTED TO ASK YOU
WAS HOW DO WE CONTROL NOT
CONTROL INFLATION BUT ALLEVIATE
INFLATION FOR CALIFORNIANS AND-
THIS- IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED WAYS TO
PUSH MONEY TO CALIFORNIANS AS A
WAY TO. ASSIST THEM WITH RISING
COSTS A LOT OF THAT FOCUS HAS
BEEN ON THE COST OF GASOLINE
WHICH WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY-
IT DOESN'T. IT DOESN'T. A FACT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN- THE SAME WAY
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT PROPOSALS
TO DO IT THROUGH OWNERSHIP OF
CARS BUT- I'D LIKE TO TOUCH ON
THAT DOCTOR NIKOLSBURG ON ON HOW
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
CALIFORNIANS I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO. ASK YOU TO- TWAY IN ON KIND
OF THE BIGGER PICTURE HOW DOES
GIVING CASH SUPPORT TO
CONSUMERS- AT THE SAME TIME IT
HELPING THEM PAY FOR INCREASED
COSTS- IMPACT. THAT THE UPWARD
PRESSURES ON INFLATION AS WELL
THANK YOU DOCTOR NIKOLSBURG. THE
USER THERE TWO QUESTIONS THE
FIRST IS HOW CAN CALIFORNIA
ALLEVIATE. INFLATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS MOST OF WHAT
HOUSEHOLDS BY IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS OUR OUR OUR PURCHASE IS
PURCHASED IN NATIONAL MARKETS
AND THEREFORE THERE'S VERY
LITTLE THAT THE STATE CAN DO TO
ALLEVIATE. INCREASES IN NATIONAL
PRICES THEY'RE VERY FEW THINGS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE PURCHASED ONLY IN OUR LOCAL
MARKETS ONE OF WHICH OF COURSE
IS HOUSING. AND WE KNOW THAT-
HOME PRICES HAVE BEEN GOING UP
AND THEY THEY SHOULD. INDICATE
THAT IN TERMS OF THE GASOLINE
PRICES WILL PRICES ARE
DETERMINED IN WORLD MARKETS. SO
CALIFORNIANS COULD BE SUBSIDIZED
IN THEIR PURCHASES OF GASOLINE
IT MEANS THAT. WE CALIFORNIANS
WILL PURCHASE MORE GASOLINE AND
BECAUSE WE HAVE A SPECIFIC BLEND
OF GASOLINE. THE FORMER AIR
QUALITY REASONS AT THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOME IMPACT BUT MY GUESS IS
THAT IT'S GOING TO HAVE ONLY
MARGINAL IMPACT AND NOT ONE THAT
IS REALLY GOING TO BE FELT VERY
MUCH BY HOUSEHOLDS. AND I'M
SORRY THERE'S A SECOND PART OF
THE QUESTION WELL I THINK LASTLY
WHILE WE TRY TO LEVY EIGHT THE
PRESSURE OF INFLATION ON
CALIFORNIANS DOES PUSHING
CASTING CALIFORNIANS INCREASE.
THE ACTUAL UPPER PRESSURE ON ON
PRICES BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
DEMAND FOR CONSUMPTION. AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN GREATER
INFLATION. THERE IS INDEED THAT
POSSIBILITY AND IT DEPENDS ON
HOW MUCH. THE INCREASED DEMANDS
FROM THE TRANSFER OF THE INCOME
TO CLIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS ND IS
FELT IN PARTICULAR MARKETS THAT
IS HOW FAST CAN SUPPLIERS OF
GOODS RESPOND TO THAT INCREASED
DEMAND. AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING BECAUSE OF THE SUPPLY
SHORTAGES TODAY IS THE SUPPLIERS
CAN'T RESPOND VERY FAST. AND IN
SAID THAT TRANSFER OF INCOME- IN
TURN RESULTS IN HIGHER PRICES-
BUT NOT MUCH ALLEVIATION OF THE
IMPACT OF INFLATION ON.
INDIVIDUALS BUDGETS. HOWEVER
THERE'S A DISTRIBUTIONAL IMPACT
AS I SAID IN MY REMARKS AS-
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LOWER
INCOME LESS AFFLUENT
CALIFORNIANS SPEND DOUBLE THE
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOME ON
FOOD THEN THE OTHER CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. AND IN BECAUSE OF
THAT. ONE CAN ALLEVIATE THE
IMPACT OF INFLATION ON THESE THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
THROUGH INCOME TRANSFERS. THANK
YOU FOR MENTIONING THAT POINT
AND SO MUCH ATTENTION HERE IN
THE CAPITAL HAS BEEN ON HOW DO
WE- GIVE MONEY TO PEOPLE TO DEAL
WITH INFLATION AND THE GOVERNOR
HAS A PROPOSAL OF A PUSHING THAT
OUT TO PEOPLE WHO. OWN A VEHICLE
SO- I THINK IT'S PROPOSALS FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER VEHICLE
OWNED BY AN INDIVIDUAL- BUT WHAT
HASN'T BEEN TALKED ABOUT IS HOW
DO WE BROADEN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE RECEIVING THIS TYPE OF
SUPPORT. AND ONE MENTION OF WHY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
DECIDED TO PUSH THIS THROUGH
OWNERSHIP OF VEHICLES IS BECAUSE
THE DMV HAS- A BETTER COMPUTER
SYSTEM TO PUSH THESE CHECKS OUR
AND IDENTIFY WHO PEOPLE ARE IN
THE STATE IN OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA OR OTHER. DEPARTMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES-
WOOD AND I AM THIS IS- I DON'T
MEAN TO GIVE YOU A POP QUIZ ON
THIS SO I I'VE I APOLOGIZE BUT
WOULD IT BE. MORE EFFECTIVE TO
REACH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE
DESCRIBED- LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IS IF WE WERE STILL
TO USE THE DMV DISTRIBUTION
pA STATE ID. MEANING I SEPARATING
THIS FROM VEHICLE OWNERSHIP BUT
ANYONE WHO HAS A STATE ID
MEANING THAT PERHAPS OTHER
PEOPLE ON PEOPLE WITH FEWER
RESOURCES I DON'T OWN VEHICLES
WOULD ALSO BE BENEFITING FROM.
THIS- CHECK DISPERSAL. SO ABSENT
THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE VARIOUS
SYSTEMS THAT THE STATE HAS. TO
IDENTIFY CALIFORNIANS- IT
ANOTHER SYSTEM WOULD- PERHAPS BE
MORE EFFICACIOUS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS
MIGHT NOT EVEN OWN AN AUTOMOBILE
THAT'S RIGHT. AND IT AS WELL
TRANSFERRING FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
EACH CAR OWNED DOESN'T RECOGNIZE
WHETHER THAT CAR USES
ELECTRICITY OR GASOLINE. AND
SELL IT IT IS A- VERY BROAD
BRUSH WAITED TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM BUT AND THERE'S A LOT OF
LEAKAGES FROM THAT AND IT
DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO ARE MOST HURT BY
INFLATION PARTICULARLY AS IT.
PERTAINS TO FOOD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT POINT- SPURRED.
MAY I TOSS IN TEN SECONDS I WAS
GONNA GIVE YOU A COUPLE
QUESTIONS TO DR SOMERSET PLEASE
JOIN IN ON THIS QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY OF THE CUTS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF. ALL DOES
ADMINISTERED THE FOOD STAMP
PROGRAM FOR USDA. WE ADMINISTER
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAMS AGAIN
FEDERAL PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY
THE STATE BUT ESPECIALLY THE
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN'S
PROGRAM. ALL OF WHICH ARE
IDENTIFYING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
ELIGIBLE FOR ALL OF FOR BENEFITS
. AND USING THAT INFORMATION-
ONE COULD TRANSFER INCOME TO
PEOPLE UP IN IN IN IN. THERE THE
FOCUS IS ON GETTING INCOME TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE AS
OPPOSED TO PICKING OUT YOUR
FAVORITE. HEADLINE PRICE THAT
WENT UP LIKE GASOLINE. AND IN
TYING THE SUBSIDIES TO THAT
BECAUSE IT IT STRIKES ME OUR-
THAT SORT OF A OF A NON ENDING
AARON THE- A CHASE YOU KNOW SO
NEXT MONTH THE HEADLINE SAYS I
DON'T KNOW EIGHT PRICES GO UP SO
WE TRY TO GET IT TO PEOPLE THAT
EAT EGGS. AND THE WEEK AFTER
THAT SO EVEN THOUGH INFLATION IS
THE OVERALL INCREASE IN PRICES
ONE WEEK IT'S ONE PRICE ONE
WEEKS IS ANOTHER GASOLINE PRICES
SPIKED. ALL UP. IT IN SO WE
CHASE GASOLINE PRICES RATHER
THAN GO DIRECTLY TO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE. SO SOMEBODY
THAT OF MAYBE A WONDERFULLY
DESERVING PERSON A FAMILY THAT
LIVES IN PACIFIC PALISADES AND
HAS FOUR CARS. GETS A CHECK FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
SIXTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS. THAT GOES
INTO SOME SAVINGS ACCOUNT
SOMEWHERE ARM. IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THE WAY WE WANT TO RESPOND
TO THESE IS A STATE IT IS. IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S A-
ACHIEVING THE OBJECTIVES THAT
MOST PEOPLE WOULD BE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS. A LOT OF US ARE SCRATCHING
OUR HEADS ON THAT ONE THANK YOU
DOCTOR SUMNER- IN THANK YOU FOR
MATCHING THE PRICE OF EGGS SO.
THOSE OF US WHO DO DRIVE OR FOR
ON A BUS OR WHOEVER WALKING WE
SEE A LOT OF SIGNS ON STREET
CORNERS ABOUT THE PRICE OF GAS
SO IS VISUALLY IN OUR FACES AND
IN OUR MIND THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE SIGNS FOR DOZEN EGGS. AND
WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A
STORE CHANGING THE PRICE ONCE A
WEEK TWICE A WEEK TO LET US KNOW
VARIATION EGG PRICES ARE A
GALLON OF MILK- AND PERHAPS
MAYBE IF THEY DID THAT WE WOULD
BE MORE SENSITIVE TO IT- BUT MY
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER IS
MAKING A LOT OF EGGS THESE DAYS
IT'S YOU KNOW GOOD ENTRY POINTS
INTO COOKING AT HOME. SO SO I
HAVE NOTICED AG PRICES AND WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT NATIONAL-
PRICE MAKING ON COMMODITY. BUT
NOT AS MUCH ABOUT REGIONAL
VARIATION SO I LIVE IN THE NORTH
BAY IN IN MARIN COUNTY VERY
HEALTHY AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
FOR EGGS AS WELL AS MILK AND
OTHER PRODUCTS AND- AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF LOCAL
PROVIDERS. IN OUR STORES- FOR
THOSE COMMODITIES DO WE SEE MORE
LOCAL AT YOU KNOW DOCTOR NICHOLS
FOR TALK ABOUT HOUSING PRICES
BUT DO WE SEE MORE LOCAL PRICES
FOR SOME OF THOSE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS OR KNOWS THAT ALSO TIED
INTO THESE. THESE NATIONAL
PRICES. UP IT IS IN THE CASE OF
ACHES ITS THE- INTERESTINGLY YOU
KNOW ABOVE PROFESSORS LIKE
COMPLICATED THINGS SO THAT WE
CAN TRY TO FIGURE HIM OUT SO BUT
BUT LET ME JUST SAY ABOUT ACHES
A CALIFORNIA IS A BIT OF A
SEPARATE MARKET THE AVIAN
INFLUENZA NATIONALLY HAS RAISED
THE PRICE OF CALIFORNIA ACHES
GENERALLY BUT IS YOU KNOW WE'VE
NOW IMPLEMENTED THE IT'LL BE A
PORTIONS OF A PROP TWELVE WHICH
SAID THE EGGS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
BE CAGE AT LEAST CAGE FREE. ALL
CAGE FREE EGGS COST 50% OR SO.
SOMETIMES DOUBLE WHAT
CONVENTIONAL EGGS DO. SO IF YOU
WERE TO TAKE A QUICK TRIP TO
CHICAGO OR OR OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
YOU'D FIND EGGS A LOT CHEAPER
THAN THEY ARE IN MARIN COUNTY.
BUT ALL IT TAKES NATIONALLY
ALMOST ALL ACHES NATIONALLY OF
SPIKED. WELL BECAUSE OF THIS
AVIAN INFLUENZA IT ALSO HAPPENED
TO HEAR THE THESE THESE DISEASE
ISSUES. WHITE FOR HUMANS THEY
COMING GOAL AND INFLUENZA IS A
IS A CHICKEN DISEASE IT'S QUITE
COMMON AND WHEN IT'S BAD EIGHT
PRICES GO UP NATIONALLY. BUT THE
OTHER THING ABOUT A CRISIS I- I
SHOULD SAY IS LOCALLY PRODUCED
EGGS JUST ABOUT ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY ARE A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN THE NATIONAL LAKE PRICE. IN
THE REASON IS PEOPLE TEND TO
PRODUCE SPECIALLY ACHES SO IN
MARIN COUNTY YOU WILL HAVE. A
NOT JUST CAGE FREE BUT FREE
RANGE OR WHAT SOMETIMES WHAT'S
CALLED PASTURE RAISED EGGS. OF
THEIR- LOTS CONSUMERS LIKE COME.
UP BUT BUT THEY'RE STILL ONE OR
2% OF ALL THE EGGS CONSUMED IN
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY ARE A
LOT MORE EXPENSIVE. BUT THEY
HAVE UNLIKE SOME LOCAL PRODUCTS
THAT CAN BE CHEAPER IN AEGS THEY
TEND TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THERE. ARE VERY MUCH A
SPECIALTY PRODUCT. YEAH THAT IS
A LOT BETTER TO- AND IF AND IF
YOU CAN AFFORD IT THAT'S GREAT
YEAH THAT'S A GOOD POINT SO WE-
WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT THIS
ENTIRE PANDEMIC- THE CRIPPLING
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN. AND I'D SAY
LIKE THE MOST FAMOUS ONE OF THIS
MOMENT WHICH WHICH PROBABLY
ISN'T. FACTOR THE INFLATION
STORY DOESN'T FACTOR INTO WHAT
HAPPENED A BABY FORMULA- I THINK
THAT'S A SERIES OF LOTS OF
UNFORTUNATE POLICIES AND EVENTS
THAT THAT IMPACTED THAT- BUT DO
WE DO WE SEE THE IMPACTS OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES. ALSO
DRIVING UP COSTS BECAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH THEN THE LACK OF
PRODUCTION BECAUSE THE HOARDINGS
SUPPRESSED PURCHASE SCENE AND
THEN NOW THE DEMAND IS RISING
THAT THAT SUPPLY DOESN'T EXIST
AND SO THERE IS INCREASED COST.
UP THERE THAT'S NOT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A BIG FACTOR I'M SURE
THEIR CASES WERE WERE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT HAPPENED. UP THE
BIGGEST ISSUE FOR US SUPPLY
CHAIN DISRUPTIONS AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE FARMS AND
RANCHES HERE HAS BEEN THE PORT
DISRUPTIONS IN UP THAT ACTUALLY
MAKE FOOD PRICES SLIGHTLY LOWER
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN IN THE U.
S. SO OFTEN PRICES I MENTIONED
WALNUT PRICES BUT ALMOND PRICES
ARE ALSO GOING TO BE A BIT LOWER
THAN THEY'D OTHERWISE BE.
BECAUSE SHE SHIPPING CONTAINERS
HAVE BEEN HARD TO FIND WHICH
MEANS EXPORTS ARE DOWN WHICH
MEANS THE A BIT MORE OF THOSE
ALMONDS OR INTO THE IN THE U. S.
MARKET. AND THAT HAS A- AFFECT
LOWERING PRICES AND THAT'S TRUE
FOR SEVERAL. A PROCESSING
TOMATOES AND A FEW OTHER- OF
AGRICULTURAL OUTPUTS THAT ARE
BETTER OFF. IT HEAVILY EXPORTED.
THEY WOULD BE EVEN MORE
EXPENSIVE IN CALIFORNIA THAN THE
REST OF THE UNITED STATES IF
THEY DIDN'T FACE THE PORT
DISRUPTIONS. ME IS ALSO FACE
SOME OF THOSE SAME PORT
DISRUPTIONS AND MEAT PRICES HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE HEADLINES FOR
HIGH PRICES FOR A NUMBER OF
SUPPLY DISRUPTION REASONS. BUT
OF THE PORT ISSUE PROBABLY KEEPS
BECAUSE WE EXPORT MEAT FROM THE
UNITED STATES PROBABLY KEEPS A
MEAT PRICES SOMEWHAT. LOWER THAN
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE SO THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CAN CUT BOTH WAYS
FOR CONSUMERS. YOU MENTIONED UP
OF BABY FOOD IN IT AND IT'S A
CORD OR BETA A MILK UP OF.
FORMULA FOR BABIES AND THAT'S A
VERY SPECIAL ITEM IS YOU KNOW A
SIX YEAR 70% OF THE BABY FORMULA
IS PURCHASED THROUGH A
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM. OF THE WICK
PROGRAM AND IN VERY. IN IN
THERE'S A COMPLICATED SYSTEM OF
WHO IS ALLOWED TO PRODUCE MILK
FOR EACH STATE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND IT'S- BASICALLY A-
SYSTEM THAT SORT OF SEEM PRIMED
FOR DISRUPTION IT ANYTIME THERE
WAS A SHOCK AND OF COURSE WE HAD
A FEW OF THOSE. SO IT'S A PRETTY
SPECIALIZED SYSTEM. I WOULD SAY
IN IN OTHER AREAS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN ARM. HAS BEEN IN- WHAT I
LIKE TO SAY IS IF YOU HAVE YOUR
SPECIALIZED BRAND OF SOMETHING
OF THERE'S A REASONABLE CHANCE
IT'S GOING TO BE DELAYED AND YOU
MAY YOU MAY MISS OUT. IN THE
SAME WITH MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS
IF YOU WERE WILLING TO TAKE
WHATEVER WAS THERE. YOU'RE
PROBABLY ALRIGHT BUT MOST OF US
HAVE. SLOUGHED TASTES AND
PREFERENCES THAT LIMIT WHAT WE
WHAT WE'RE WILLING TO BUY. INTO
THE SUPPLY CHAIN GETS INTO THAT.
I DON'T SEE THAT IS A MAJOR
INFLATION CONTRIBUTOR WHAT IS A
MAJOR CONTRACT. INFLATION
CONTRIBUTOR AS WE HEARD A FEW
MINUTES AGO IS THE PRICE OF FUEL
SO FOOD HAS TO BE MOVED AROUND
WHETHER IT'S- IN A PICKUP TRUCK
TO YOUR FARMERS MARKET OR ON THE
TRAIN OUT. YOU KNOW BRINGING
MEAT FROM THE MIDWEST IN BOTH OF
THOSE USE UEL AND THEY BOTH
RAISE THE COST OF FEED OF FOOD
AT RETAIL. RELATIVE TO THE PRICE
OF. THE COMMODITY AT THE FARM. I
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO DR
TERRY NICHOLS BURKE UCLA
ANDERSON SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT
AND THEN JUST NOW DR DANIEL
SUMNER UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU BOTH SO
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE
PANEL IN THIS HEARING- WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOU- CONTRIBUTION
TO OUR BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
INFLATION AND ITS IMPACT ON OUR
FOOD SYSTEMS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
CALL UP PANEL NUMBER TWO AND
SOME PEOPLE ARE HERE PHYSICALLY
IN SUMMER HERE VIRTUALLY SO I'LL
JUST MENTION ALL FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GOING TO BE JOINING US
ON PENALTY WHICH IS IMPACTS OF
INFLATION ON FOOD SECURITY
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE BECKY
SILVA OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS MEG
DAVIDSON OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN MARIN FOOD BANK. BENYAMIN
CHAO OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER AND CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. SO IF YOU ARE HERE
PHYSICALLY COME ON UP AND-
VIRTUAL MEMBERS WE WILL- CALLED
WE HAVE BECKY OR PARDON ME MS
SILVA OR MS DAVIDSON- AVAILABLE
NOW ONLINE. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MISS SILVA OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS- YOU
ARE FIRST. EVERYBODY IS
CONFIRMING THAT YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY I CAN HEAR YOU AND I CAN
SEE YOU THANK YOU. OKAY RIGHT HI
MY NAME IS BECKY SO ABOUT I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. ARE YOU
HAPPY REPRESENTS FORTY ONE FOOD
BANKS THAT PARTNER WITH OVER
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED AGENCY
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE I'M IN
OUR MISSION IS TO END HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA. UNDER ALARMING HIGH
CALIFORNIA'S. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SINCE JANUARY FOOD INSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN RISING
STEADILY. THE LATEST DATA SHOWS
THAT EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS
OR JUST OVER 20% OF OUR
POPULATION ARE EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY. WITH REPEAT
DISPARITIES FOR BLACK AND LATIN
TAX COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THIS IS A
DOUBLE THE PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS
MORE THAN. TWO YEARS INTO THE
PROCESS. SO IT'S NO. THAT A
RECENT SURVEY OF WORK MEETINGS
FOUND THAT NEARLY HALF OFF.
ORDER THAT THEY'RE SERVING
BETWEEN DOUBLE TO TRIPLE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. FOR EXAMPLE
LAST MONTH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK REPORTED
THAT THEY HAD THE BUSIEST EIGHT
DAYS THAT THEY'VE HAD IN A YEAR
AND A HALF AT ONE OF THEIR
DISTRIBUTION SITES. WE KNOWFROM
THE GEAT RECESSION THAT THE
CRISIS IN FOOD INSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA IS FAR FROM OVER- IF
YOU BANKS ARE ANTICIPATING THAT
THEY WILL HAVE TO SUSTAIN
CURRENT LEVELS OF DEMAND FOR
FOOD FOR YEARS TO COME. AT THE
SAME TIME THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE
SEEKING FOOD ASSISTANCE WE'RE
FACING A DANGEROUS FEDERAL FOOD
AND BENEFITS FLAT. WHILE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED A
REALLY ROBUST INITIAL RESPONSE
TO THE COLD AT NINETEEN CRISIS.
EXPERIENCED A FEDERAL WHO. LEFT
MORE THAN 83% FROM. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I
WANTED TO SHARE A QUICK QUOTE
FROM THE CO CEO OF THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK WHICH IS AN
FRESNO. AND SHE'S GOT IT
HISTORICALLY TEETH OUT PROVIDED
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WITH
ROUGHLY 25% OF THE FOODS THAT WE
DISTRIBUTE IT. BUT THIS YEAR WE
WILL LIKE YOU RECEIVED YOU FELT
FOOD TOTALING ONLY 15% OF THE
TOTAL YOU DISTRIBUTE WE SIMPLY
CAN'T. MAKE UP THIS DIFFERENCE
ON OUR OWN. SO ON TOP OF
DEFINING FEATHER SUPPORT FOR
FOOD BANKS PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
CALFRESH OR SNAP. OFF I REALLY
AREN'T WILL BE FACED WITH A
DRAMATIC REDUCTION IN THEIR FOOD
BENEFITS WHEN THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY STATUS SUNSET.
ON AS EARLY AS MID JULY SO WHEN
THIS HAPPENS CALFRESH RECIPIENTS
WILL LOSE ON AVERAGE ABOUT
EIGHTY TWO DOLLARS PER MONTH. IN
EMERGENCY OFTEN. STATEWIDE ABOUT
NEED A REDUCTION BY NEARLY HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS PER MONTH IN
BENEFITS TAKEN FROM THE FOOD
ECONOMY. COMPOUNDED BY OF COURSE
RECORD SETTING FOOD PRICE
INFLATION FROM RELATED SUPPLY.
INDEX REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THE
GROCERY PRICES HAVE RISEN BY
ALMOST 11% IN THE PAST YEAR
WHICH IS THE LARGEST TWELVE
MONTH INCREASING GROCERY PRICES
IN NEARLY FORTY TWO YEARS. TELL
FOR EXAMPLE SACRAMENTO FOOD BANK
AND FAMILY SERVICES REPORTS THE
PRICE THEY ARE PAYING FOR IT
DOESN'T HAVE. DOUBLED IN RECENT
MONTHS FROM NINETY THREE CENTS
PER DOZEN TO TWO DOLLARS AND
TWENTY CENTS PER DAY. IN A
RECENT SURVEY WE ALSO ASKED
HOUSEKEEPING'S ARE COPING WITH
THE COST OF FOOD AND FREE
INCREASING AND THAT MOST
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE USED A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THEIR
ANNUAL FEE PURCHASE BUDGET
ALREADY REJECTING ME. AND THAT
THEY- INCREASED FUNDRAISING
EFFORTS. SOMETHING WE EVEN HAVE
TO OFFER FOOD LESS OFTEN AND
HAVE YOU KIND OF HAD TO CLOSE
DISTRIBUTION SITE. SO WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF A REALLY DANGEROUS
SITUATION WHERE MORE PEOPLE ARE
HUNGRY. YOUR BANKS ARE GETTING
LESS FEDERAL SUPPORT.
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE LEFT
CALPERS DOLLARS TO SPEND YEAH
BUT PROSECUTORS GOING UP SO I
JUST CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH HOW
CRITICAL THE SITUATION IS AND
HOW DESPERATELY WE NEED A
PROPORTIONATE STATE INVESTMENT.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL
IMPROVEMENTS SOLUTIONS THAT
SUPPORT FOOD BANKS IS HEALTHY.
WHICH PROVIDES STATE FUNDING TO
BE BANKS AND I'M AN EMERGENCY
FOOD PROVIDERS TO PURCHASE
CALIFORNIA GROWN. IT'S A WIN WIN
FOR CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN
THIS MOMENT THAT THE FOOD
ECONOMY IS SO DEEPLY IMPACTED.
HOW GOOD IS ALSO INCREDIBLY
EFFICIENT. EACH DOLLAR ENABLE
STUDENTS TO PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MEALS AND
HELP YOU TO ALSO ALLOWS FOOD
BEING SERVING DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BUY FOOD UNIQUELY SUITED FOR THE
POPULATIONS THAT THEY SERVE. AND
ALLOW THEM TO PURCHASE MORE
EXPENSIVE ITEMS LIKE PROTEINS
THAT ARE RARE AND YOU DON'T.
THIS YEAR WE'RE ASKING GOVERNING
ASM AND ALTHOUGH JIM LEADERS TO
INCLUDE A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
FOR THE HEALTHY PROGRAM IN OUR
STATE BUDGET. WHICH IS IN LINE
WITH THE STATE'S SUPPORT THAT
WAS PROVIDED LAST YEAR. WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A ONE TIME FOR HEALTH
FOOD IN HIS JANUARY TENTH
BUDGET- BUT WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
BUT NO ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
WERE PROPOSED IN HIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. WE'RE CALLING ON
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING HELP YOU
OUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
INCLUDINGSIXTY MILLION ON
GOING. TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
KEEP SERVING THOUSANDS OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO RELY N
THEM EVERY DAY. WE'RE SO
THANKFUL ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AND SENATOR LAYERED- ARE
CHAMPIONING OUR REQUEST THIS
YEAR. I'M IN ADDITION TO SUPPORT
FOR FOOD BANKS I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT I REQUEST TO PROVIDE
STATE FUNDING FOR OUR RAMPS DOWN
APPROACH TO HELP RUSSIAN
MERCHANTS THE ALLOTMENTS. SO I'M
NOT SURE A MOMENT AGO CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS WALL LOSE ABOUT
EIGHTY TWO DOLLARS PER PERSON
PER MONTH. WHEN YOU CAN
REDEVELOPMENT AND- AT A TIME
WHEN FOOD DOLLARS ARE ALREADY
STRETCHED REALLY. THIN WITH THE
COST OF FOOD GOING UP. BUT WE
CAN'T LET THE EXTRA. AND
PREMATURELY. NOT ONLY DOES
CALFRESH SUPPORT PEOPLE IN
PURCHASING FOOD AT THEIR OWN
CONVENIENCE. BUT IT IS ALSO AN
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC STIMULUS. FOR
EACH DOLLAR SPENT IT GENERATES A
DOLLAR ET AND ECONOMIC
ACTIVITIES. AND THINGS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES MAXIMIZING THIS
OPPORTUNITY THE CURRENT IMPACT
OF EMERGENCY ALLOTMENT ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS OVER.
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR MONTHS. SO WE'RE ASKING-
BUDGET YEARS YOU JUST HAVE OUR
TO HELP MITIGATE THIS ONE. AND
LAST WEEK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CELEBRATE THE TREMENDOUS
EXCITEMENT THE PANDEMIC ET
PROGRAM AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR MAXIMIZING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FEED HUNGRY CHILDREN THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM. I DON'T THINK YOU
DON'T KNOW PDT IS A PROGRAM THAT
WAS AUTHORIZED BY THE FAMILIES
FIRST ACT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. EITHER WAY TO
PROVIDE FEW BENEFITS TO CHILDREN
WHO ARE MISSING SCHOOL MEALS
BECAUSE SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED.
TODAY ALMOST FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PANDEMIC. YOU NEED
YOU BENEFITS HAVE BEEN SPENT.
WE'RE REALLY HOPEFUL THAT THE
VITAMINS FIVE MINUTES. AND THE
USDA WILL APPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
PLAN FOR THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR
AS WELL. ALL STOP THEIR THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING YOU TO
SHARE OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THIS I
AM VERY TIMELY AND CRITICAL
TOPIC AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS OVER AND I'M GOING TO NEED
TO RE ORDER- THE PANEL AS I HAD
ANNOUNCED IT- DUE TO A TIME
CONSTRAINT FOR A MEMBER OF THE A
PARTICIPANT IN THE PANEL A
MISTER CHOW FROM THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR REMINDING THE TIME- SO HI MY
NAME IS BENJAMIN CHOW AND POLICY
ANALYST AT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. AND MY
A AREA OF EXPERTISE IS TRACKING-
FOOD INSECURITY AMONG AFRICAN
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA- SO
TODAY I WILL HOPE TO DO WHAT I
CAN TO ADD TO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW- PRICE INCREASES
PARTICULARLY FOR FOOD AND
BEVERAGE WHICH IS A BASIC NEEDS
FOR ALL OF US- HAVE EXACERBATED
. IN EQUITIES AND INSECURE AMONG
AFRICAN POP. I'M AND AS YOU KNOW
THE COVERED PANDEMIC IS
COMPOUNDED WITH INFLATION TO
DRIVE INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES FOR
IMMIGRANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA- SO
I'LL START WITH AN ANALYSIS DONE
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR BY THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THEY SURE
THAT. THEY FOUND THAT THE PRICES
IN THE PACIFIC ARE UP EIGHT
POINT TWO PERCENT. A RATE
SIMILAR TO THE US OVERALL RATE
OF EIGHT POINT FIVE PERCENT- AND
THESE INCREASES HAVE BEEN DRIVEN
AND FOOD AND BEVERAGE ENERGY AND
GASOLINE- THE P. P. I SEE ALSO
ESTIMATES THAT THE LOWEST INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE EXPERIENCED AN
OVERALL PRICE INCREASE OF NINE
POINT SIX PERCENT. OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS WHILE HIGHER INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE SEEN SOMETHING
MORE LIKE EIGHT POINT TWO
PERCENT. I AND DOLLAR TERMS. TO
PURCHASE THE SAME THINGS THAT
THEY BOUGHT IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE LOWEST FIFTH OF IT IN INCOME
BRACKET FAMILIES. WE NEED TO
SPEND AN ADDITIONAL THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR SO
WE'RE SEEING AN EX AN EXTREME
BURDEN ON LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND SO. I'LL BE FOCUSING ON LOW.
INCOME IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES- SO
CAP C. ALONG OUR FRIENDS NURSE
CAL. REESE PARTNERED WITH THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH AND
POLICY RESEARCH- TO LOOK AT A
STATE SURVEY DATA AND EXAMINE
OUR FOOD SECURITY AMONG
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. AND
WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT MORE THAN
TWO IN FIVE OR FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. I HAVE REPORTED
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY- IN
THE PAST AND IN TWENTY TWENTY.
SO FOR REFERENCE THE AVERAGE
RATE OF FOOD SECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA- USING- USDA DATA
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY. IS NINE POINT 8% SO THIS
RATE IS SEVERELY HIGHER THAN
THAN THE NATIONAL DATA THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE- WE ALSO FOUND
THAT RATES OF FOOD INSECURITY
ARE ESPECIALLY ACUTE FOR
CHILDREN. A 64% OF UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN ACCORDING TO THIS YOU
SEE ONLY STUDY- I REPORTED ARE
ARE AFFECTED BY FOOD INSECURITY-
AND SO TO ILLUSTRATE HOW THIS.
SHOWS UP IN SOMEONE'S LIFE- I
WANT TO SHARE AN ANECDOTE FROM A
HURLING. SHE IS A MOTHER THAT WE
SPOKE TO SHE LIVES IN LINDSAY
CALIFORNIA IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. SHE SAYS I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS REPORT ON THE U.
S. MY DAUGHTERS HAD CALFRESH BUT
MY HUSBAND AND I WERE NOT ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE SO THERE TO MIX
THAT IS FAMILY. OF THE LIMITED
BENEFITS FROM CONFERENCE WERE
NOT ENOUGH TO FEED MY WHOLE
FAMILY. AND MANY TIMES WE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH FOOD. AND DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ALL OF US GOT
CODED AND LYFT BECAME MORE
DIFFICULT. WE COULDN'T WORK
IMPAIR BILLS IT WAS VERY PAINFUL
TELLING MY DAUGHTER THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE MILK. AND HAVING TO
PUT HER TO BED WITHOUT SOME TO
EAT. I'M IN RECENTLY I SPOKE TO
ANOTHER UNDOCUMENTED MOTHER WHO
LIVES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND ANNOUNCER TO SHARE HER STORY
SHE SHE- MADE EVERY EVERY BIG
POINT TO. A POINT OUT THE PRICE
OF EGGS NO CONVENIENCE BASIC
NECESSITY SHE'S NOTICING IN HER
COMMUNITY. HAVE RISEN IN PRICE-
AND IT'S ADDING ADDITIONAL
STRESS AND CONSTRAINTS ON HER
FAMILY'S BUDGET- SO- YOU KNOW
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO GET ACROSS
TODAY'S THAT THIS HARDSHIP AS
YOU NO. INFLATION IS GONE IT FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES IS.
EXACERBATING FOOD AND SECURITY
BUT IT'S- IT'S A CYCLE OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND POVERTY THAT HAS
PERSISTED FOR A LOT OF FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY IN WORKING FAMILIES-
OF. FOR THE UCLA THE UCLA DATA
WE FOUND THAT FROM THE YEARS
TWENTY ELEVEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
FOOD INSECURITY RATES AMONG US
NONCITIZEN ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVE BEEN RANGING FROM 37% TO
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT- AND FOR THE
SAME YEARS THE PERCENTAGE OF
NONCITIZENS AND HOUSEHOLDS WITH
INCOME BELOW THE- FEDERAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD. RANGE FROM
24% TO TWENTY TO FORTY PERCENT.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS HISTORY
OF SUSTAIN HARDSHIP DEMONSTRATES
THE NEED FOR SYSTEMIC SOLUTIONS-
THAT'S THAT DISRUPT THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY AND MITIGATE FOOD
INSECURITY AND THE LONG TERM- SO
I'LL JUST MOVE ON TO WHAT- SOME
PROPOSALS THAT WE'D WE'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT- FOR THE STATE- TO
CONSIDER TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS FACING HARDSHIP.
I'M PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS. OF THE
FIRST PROPOSAL- BECAUSE DUBBED
FOOD FOR ALL IT'S BEING ADVANCED
AS SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY FOUR.
AUTHORED BY SENATOR MELISSA HER
TITLE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY- AND
THERE'S ALSO THERE ALSO BUDGET
ASKS BEING LED BY HER TADO AND
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO-
THE GOAL FOOD FALLS TO AND THE
EXCLUSION OF CALIFORNIANS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA. FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR C. FAB. ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
SO I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
ATTENTION I WAS BROUGHT TO
CALIFORNIA. AND SNAP AS A WAY TO
MITIGATE THE PRESSURES WE'VE
SEEN OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE OVER
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS. THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE EXCLUDED FROM CALIFORNIA SHE
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE INCOME
ELIGIBLE. THE L. A. O. JUST
RELEASED A REPORT. AND THEY
DIDN'T ANALYSIS AND THEY
ESTIMATE ANYWHERE FROM SIX.
1-009-000-0800 FORTY THOUSAND.
INDIVIDUALS ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED- AND- IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR THE GOVERNOR
INTRODUCED A PROPOSAL TO MAKE C.
FIVE AVAILABLE TO INCOME
ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS AGES FIFTY FIVE AND
OLDER- BUT PEOPLE BELOW THE AGE
OF FIFTY FIVE UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL WILL CONTINUE TO BE
EXCLUDED AND O THAT'S WHERE. WE
AS ADVOCATES ARE CONTINUING TO.
I BRING THIS UP WITH WITH OUR
ELECTED LEADERS INCLUDING YOU-
JUST TO GO OVER THE COST- THAT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR ALLOCATES THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR PLANNING PURPOSES- WE EXPECT
THE LIVE DATE TO BE IS.
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO BE AS
EARLY AS JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR- AND INCREASED WATER
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE-
ALSO THE SENATE- PUBLISHED ITS-
BUDGET BLUEPRINT AND INCLUDED
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ITS PROPOSAL. FOR
FOOD FOR ALL FOR ALL AGES SO
THEY WON'T BE ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- AND THAT WOULD FUND A
FULL A HALF OF YOUR BENEFITS
STARTING JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO WE'RE SEEING SOME STRONG
SUPPORT AND THE SENATE- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE MAY REVISE WE
DIDN'T SEE ANY INCREASE IN THE
AND THE AGE CATEGORIES FOR FOOD
FOR ALL FROM THE GOVERNOR. A
DESPITE THIS GROWING URGENCY TO
MITIGATE FOOD AND SECURITY AND
THE PERSISTING EFFECTS THAT WILL
HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES- SO WE
ARE ASKING OF OUR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO JOIN OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE. AND PRIORITIZE FOOD FOR
ALL FOR ALL AGES SO THAT WE HAVE
NO EXCEPTIONS AND EXCLUSIONS.
AND OUR FOOD SAFETY THAT- THE
OTHER PROPOSAL I WANT TO UPLIFT
IS. BEING LED BY OUR FRIENDS AT
NURSE CALIFORNIA IT'S S. B. ONE
FOUR EIGHT ONE. AUTHORED BY
BECKER STEPPED OF FOOD WITH CARE
AND IS ALSO A BUDGET PROPOSAL
BEING LED BY A WICKS- SO- ALL
CHILDREN DESERVE TO BE WELL
NOURISHED AND THRIVED- THRIVE
BUT UNDERLYING FEDERAL RULES FOR
CHILD CARE MEAL PROGRAMS. KEEP
MANY CHILDREN FROM ACCESSING A
CHRISTIAN AND AFFORDABLE FOOD.
AND EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC A
FEDERAL RULES AND BEING PERSONS
DIDN'T ADEQUATELY ACCOUNT FO
THE COST OF LIVING- AND THE COST
OF PROVIDING. QUALITY CHILDCARE
I INCLUDING NUTRITIOUS MEALS FOR
CALIFORNIA- SO WHAT THE SPIKE OF
FOOD COSTS ARE DUE TO INFLATION
PROVIDERS ARE BEING FORCED TO
PAY OUT OF THEIR POCKET. TO PAY
FOR HEALTHY MEALS FOR CHILDREN.
IN CHILD CARE- DESPITE
OFTENTIMES OPERATING ON RAZOR
THIN OPERATING BUDGET MARGINS.
SO WITH FOOD PRICES RANGING FROM
YOU KNOW ELEVATING FROM EIGHT TO
TEN PERCENT. HI THERE IS A
STRONG NEED FOR ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING TO ADEQUATELY COMPENSATE
PROVIDERS FOR THE MEALS THEY
SERVE- THE FOOD WITH CARE
PROPOSAL CURRENTLY BEING
CONSIDERED- N THE STATE BUDGET
PROCESS WOULD ENSURE FUNDING FOR
FREE MEALS FOR ALL KIDS IN
ADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
PROVIDERS IN NAME IT WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE THE AYE REIMBURSEMENT
PAY A PENALTY FOR CHILD CARE
MEALS- WHICH ONLY COMPENSATES
FAMILY DAY CARE PROVIDERS 475%
OF THE MEALS THAT THEY SERVE-
THE STATUS OF THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- THIS JUST THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE AND
ADVANCE THE BUDGET REQUEST. FOR
A CALL FOOD WITH CARE- AND ASKED
THAT IT BE INCLUDED IN THE FINAL
STATE BUDGET- SO I'LL JUST CLOSE
BY SAYING THAT AS RISING FOOD
PRICES EAT AWAY AT THE GROCERY
BUDGETS. OF ALL OF US- OUR
LEADERS MUST PIVOT TO A STATE
RELIEF PACKAGE THAT IS EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE IN SPECIFIC- TO
THE RANGE OF NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- SO CONFESSIONS HE
FELT HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WEATHERING THE
PANDEMIC- AND EVERYONE LIVING IN
OUR STATE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
STATUS OR AGE WILL BENEFIT FOR
YEARS TO COME IF WE- INVEST NOW-
IN THE GYM BUDGET. AND SO WE CAN
CREDIT CALIFORNIA WHERE EVERYONE
HAS A PLATE AT THE DINNER TABLE
SUPPOSE THERE AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSALS ON I CAN STAY. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAO WILL GO
BACK TO OUR VIRTUAL
PARTICIPANTS- MS DAVIDSON FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD
BANK. REFERENCE NUMBER MAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. TODAY EVERY
SCHEDULING THIS HEARING. MY NAME
IS MARY DAVIDSON AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD
BANK. THERE IS CURRENTLY BEGINS
THE LARGEST TERRIBLE FOOD
PROVIDER IN OUR TO TURN SERVICE
AREA AND WE HAVE SEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOHN INCLUDES. OUR
FOOD ASSISTANCE REQUEST SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF HER BACK AND WE
ARE CURRENTLY DISTRIBUTING FOOD
TO OVER FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS EVERY SINGLE WEEK. UP
FROM THIRTY TWO THOUSAND BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. AND DESPITE
REPORTED IMPROVEMENTS IN SOME
MACROECONOMIC INDICATORS LIKE
REDUCE UNEMPLOYMENT. THE DEMAND
ON THE GROUND FOR FREE FOOD IS
NOT WHEN. IN FACT VISITS TO OUR
ONLINE FOOD LOCATOR TOOL HAVE
BEEN TRENDING CONSISTENTLY
UPWARD SINCE DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR. AND CALLS TO OUR CALVET
APPLICATION HOTLINE ARE UP 20%
SINCE THE START OF THIS YEAR.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE TURNING
TO THE FOOD BANK EVERY MONTH
LOOKING FOR HELP TO MAKE THEIR
STRAIN HOUSEHOLD BUDGETS SOMEHOW
TIED OUT. I WOULD USE MY TIME
HERE TODAY O SHARE THE IMPACT
NOT ONLY ON COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK. BUT
ON THOSE WE SERVE. LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS OF ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE REGIONS IN THE
COUNTRY. SIMPLY PUT INFLATION IS
HITTING THOSE ON THE LOWEST
INCOMES THE HARDEST. AS FAMILIES
STRUGGLE OF BALANCING
INCREASINGLY HIGH COST OF
LIVING. AND RISING FOOD PRICES.
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY ARE
HURTING. STILL STRUGGLING FROM
THE AFTERMATH OF COATED. IN A
SURVEY OF OVER SEVEN THOUSAND OF
OUR PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS. 81% OF
THEM SAID THEY HAD NOT RECOVERED
FINANCIALLY FOR PANDEMIC. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK. A 12%
INCREASE IN GROCERY COSTS IS NOT
A SMALL JOB. ESPECIALLY WHEN
COMBINED WITH RISING GAS PRICES
INCREASED COST OF CHILDCARE AND
RUNS THAT ARE CLIMBING. THE
MAKING REALLY TOUGH CHOICES
ABOUT WHERE AND HOW TO CUT BACK
. WHAT IS YOUR STORY OF ONE OF
OUR PANTRY PARTICIPANTS WHO IS
CURRENTLY GRAPPLING WITH THESE
STRUGGLES. WHEN ANNA YESTERDAY
ACTUALLY AT ONE OF OUR POP UP
PANTRIES FOR SHE WAS PICKING UP
FOOD FOR HER FAMILY. SHE'S
ORIGINALLY FROM UKRAINE AND SHE
HAS BEEN A NURSE IN SAN
FRANCISCO SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE. HE DIDN'T CARE RECURRENCE
IN SECTION EIGHT HOUSING AND
BOTH ARE DISABLED. HE SAID THIS
ABOUT INFLATION MY PARENTS ONLY
GET SOCIAL SECURITY SO I HAVE TO
HELP THEM WITH RENT THE RENTER'S
GOT RAISED IN SOCIAL SECURITY IS
ENOUGH. IS AFFECTING ME TOO
BECAUSE I HAVE TO PAY MY OWN
RENT MY OWN FOOD THE CAR
INSURANCE EVERYTHING IS GOING UP
IN PRICE NOW. I WENT TO THE
STORE AND THE PRICES ARE CRAZY
FOR EGGS ELEVEN DOLLARS. IS
REALLY ROUGH. AS YOU WERE FROM
BACKES. HER COMMON JUST NOW FOOD
BANKS ARE NOT IMMUNE TO THESE
CHALLENGES. JUST AS MORE OF OUR
NEIGHBORS TURN TO US FOR HELP.
WE FACE GLOBAL SUPPLIES FIVE G.
Y. CHAIN ISSUES AND INFLATION.
IS DRIVING AN UNSUSTAINABLE
INCREASE IN OUR BUDGETS. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST FOOD DISTRIBUTORS
NONPROFIT OR FOR PROFIT IN OUR
COUNTIES. WE DISTRIBUTE ONE
POINT THREE MILLION POUNDS OF
FOOD EVERY SINGLE WEEK. AND
UNLIKE CISCO OR SAFE WAY OTHER
FOR PROFIT FOOD DISTRIBUTORS. WE
DON'T PASS THE COST ONTO OUR
CONSUMERS. WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT WE'RE HAVING TO ABSORB
THESE HIGH HUGE COST INCREASES
AT A RATE. THAT IS COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE. WHAT THIS MEANS
IS THAT WE ARE FORCED TO GIVE
FAMILIES LESS FOOD. AND FOOD IF
YOUR FAMILY'S. COSTS ARE
INCREASING DRAMATICALLY FOR FOOD
THAT WE HAD ALREADY PLANNED TO
PURCHASE. WE'VE HEARD A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THE PRICE OF EGGS.
AND EGGS ARE STABLE PRO IN BOTH
OUR PANTRY AND HOME DELIVERED
GROCERY PROGRAM SO WE BUY A TON
OF EGGS. BETWEEN MARCH AND APRIL
OF THIS YEAR. THE PRICE OF EGGS
NEARLY DOUBLED IN ONE WEEK. WE
EXPECT THIS TO CONTINUE CROSSING
AS AN ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE
MONTH. AND OVER 60% OF WHAT OUR
FOOD INDUSTRIES IS ACTUALLY
FRESH PRODUCE REJECTING THE COST
PER POUND OF PRODUCE WILL
INCREASE BY 11% FOR THE LAST
HALF OF THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND AT
ONE POINT THREE MILLION POUNDS
OF FOOD THAT WE DISTRIBUTE EACH
WEEK. IT IS TO BE SHIPPED TO OUR
WAREHOUSE AND THEN REDISTRIBUTED
TO OUR NETWORK OF THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOOD PANTRIES THAT
REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN FUEL. EFFICIENT WE'RE SEEING
22% INCREASE IN OUR DIESEL
COSTS. WE'VE ALSO SEEN AS AS
MICELLAR MENTIONED A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION IN FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS FISCAL
YEAR WE ONLY RECEIVE TEN MILLION
POUNDS OF FOOD COMPARED TO
THIRTY TWO MILLION LAST FISCAL
YEAR. WE DO NOT SEE RELIEF IN
SIGHT. SO WE'RE MAKING ALL OF
THIS INTO OUR BUDGETING FOR NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. THIS MEANS
POTENTIALLY NOT BEING ABLE TO
BUY AS MUCH FOOD AS WE DID THIS
YEAR OR HAVING TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD EACH FAMILY GOT
SINCE THE NEED IS CERTAINLY NOT
DECLINING. TO COMBAT THESE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE JOINED
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS IN LOBBYING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AS WEL. AS LAWMAKERS IN
THE SENATE THE ASSEMBLY TO
PRIORITIZE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CALIPHATE.
IN THE BUDGET NEXT YEAR. ALSO
GRANTS FOODBANKS FUNDING TO
PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROWN FOOD
SUPPORTING LOCAL PRODUCERS AND
COMBATING HUNGER AT THE SAME
TIME. WE'RE ALSO STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF THE FOOD FOR ALL
PROPOSALS THAT BENJAMIN JUST
MENTIONED AND THE RAMP DOWN OF
CALPERS EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE MY TIME WITH A
QUOTE FROM JUNE WHO IS A MOTHER
OF TWO TEENAGERS AND SHE
RECENTLY STARTED ATTENDING THE
ST PETER'S CHURCH FOOD PANTRY
WHICH IS IN THE MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SHE SAID IF I WASN'T ABLE TO
COME TO THE PANTRY I WILL BE
REALLY LIMITED BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS REALLY EXPENSIVE
EVEN AN ONION IF I GO TO THE
STORE. EVERYTHING HAS A HIGHER
PRICE NOW. SO IT WOULD REALLY BE
A STRUGGLE FOR ME TO EAT. IF I
WAS NOT ABLE TO COME HERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS DAVID SEN AND
NEXT WILL HAVE MISTER
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ FROM THE
RESTAURANT ENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY MISTER SANCHEZ.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME CHRISTOPHER
SCIENCES POLICY ADVOCATE THE
WESTERN CINEMA POVERTY WE WANT
TO SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE TODAY
DISCUSSES IMPORTANT ISSUES. AND
SURE WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM OUR
LEGAL PARTNERS IN THE LEGAL
SERVICE COMMUNITY AND CBO
DIRECTLY SERVING CALIFORNIANS I
WANT TO ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
MY FELLOW PANELISTS- AND REALLY
TALK ABOUT ISSUES RELATING TO
ACCESS AND THE DELIVERY OF-
BENEFITS WHETHER BE- CAL FRESH
KERR WORKS OR OTHER. SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS IT RELATES TO COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE WE KNOW THAT MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE PRESENT
ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND YET HAVE
HAVE HAVE YET TO BECOME STABLE
OR- BE WHOLE AGAIN. ONCE WHERE
THEY WERE BEFORE- AND THIS IS
EVEN MORE SO TRUE FOR
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNABLE TO
ACCESS FORMS OF FINANCIAL RELIEF
THAT WERE OFFERED IN THE MEANT
PANDEMIC INCLUDING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ON HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT'S WHY WE
BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
FIND WAYS PRIORITIZE THE
CONNECTION OF BENEFITS TO PEOPLE
WHO AND THE DELIVERY OF THOSE
BENEFITS WE'VE HEARD WE HAVE
HEARD FROM OUR PARTNERS THAT.
ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
SOME OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE HAD
COME ACROSS I AM TRYING TO
ACCESS THE BENEFITS ARE
INCLUDING. NOT BEING ABLE TO
CONNECT THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
PHONE LINES AT A COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE OFFICE AND SOME COUNTIES
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE LINE WASN'T ABLE TO MEET
THE DEMAND. WHILE COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE OFFICE HAS FOUND UNIQUE
WAYS SUCH AS TEXT MESSAGING AND
SOME COUNTIES TO COMMUNICATE
WITH RECIPIENTS REALLY WE
BELIEVE THAT COMMUNICATION CAN
IMPROVE AND GET BETTER SERVE
COMMUNITIES. ON HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A HARDER TIME
RECEIVING A DEBIT CARD AND OTHER
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ACCESS
SAFETY NET ENEFITS SUCH AS
CALFRESH- WHEN THE REQUEST OTHER
BENEFITS TO BE SENT TO POST
OFFICES IN CALIFORNIA. LET'S
POST OFFICES NO LONGER
PRIORITIZE THE GENERAL DELIVERY
SERVICE. WHICH IS ALLOWED FOR
THOSE WHO ARE WE DON'T HAVE A
STABLE ADDRESS TO RECEIVE NOW
THIS WILL. HAS MADE IT DIFFICULT
. PIECES AN ALMOST IN. FOR THE
WHO RELY ON ITS- THE- TO YOU TO
ACCESS THE BETTER. AND THAT IF
THEY CAN'T PHYSICALLY GET THEIR
CARDS. RECIPIENTS OF BENEFITS
BEING TARGETED. RECIPIENTS OF
BENEFITS SUCH AS CALFRESH HAVE
BEEN TARGETED BY SCAMMERS ARE OF
SKIMMING RECENTLY- TO ELECTRONIC
WE STILL THEIR BENEFITS ON THE
DEBIT CARDS- THROUGH A NUMBER OF
MEANS- AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
SOUND ISN'T SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA OUR PARTNERS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. HAVE YOU
GONNA SEE AN INCREASE IN THEFT.
OF THE SAFETY NET BENEFITS.
MESSENE CONTINUED TO BE A
GROWING PROBLEM WELL YOU SEEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS A COMMON
OCCURRENCE IS AN INDIVIDUAL.
WILL HAVE THEIR FOOD BENEFIT.
POSKIM JUST ENOUGH TO THE CARE
RECOGNIZE IT BUT THIS WILL OCCUR
OVER TIME- AND THIS WILL GO A
NOTICEABLE OUR ARMED FOR ARE
QUITE A FEW MONTHS UNTIL. THEY
ACTUALLY LOOK INTO HOW MUCH THAT
HAS BEEN STOLEN FROM THEM. I DO
WANNA MENTION AND APPLIED CDSS
ON THEIR MOVE TO PROVIDE NEW
DEBIT CARDS CHIU CALFRESH
RECIPIENTS. TO PREVENT THE
SCAMMING OUGHT TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE CHIPS ON THESE CARDS THAT
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT FOR SCAMS
THAT OCCUR THE CARD READERS. ARE
WHICH IS CURRENT WHICH IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE CHARGES ARE IMPORTANT
TO KNOW AS RELATES TO INFLATION
AT IS CRITICAL THE STATE
ENSURES. THAT THOSE WHO QUALIFY
TO ACCESS BENEFITS ACTUALLY ABLE
TO ACCESS ND UTILIZE THESE
BENEFITS. AND ENSURE THAT WE CAN
KEEP THEM ARE SECURE. SO
FAMILIES. CAN BE ABLE TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS AS RELATES
MORE SPECIFICALLY TO INFLATION
WE WANT IT WE JOIN MANY A LOT OF
THE KIDS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS HEARD FROM. A AN AXE FOR
GREATER INVESTMENTS IN THE
STATE'S BUDGET AND TARGET
DOLLARS TO COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING POVERTY. QUESTIONS
CENTERS BOYS SUPPORTER PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S A SAFETY NE REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS ARE THEIR
AGE. WE WOULD PER- WE WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITION WE WOULD ASK
THAT ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. BE
TARGETED TO EXISTING PROGRAMS
ARE SUCH AS CAL WORKS ARE
CARYATIDS. WE WOULD ENCOURAGE OF
LEGISLATURE WHEN THE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FORMS OF RELIEF. THAT
THEY INCLUDE GENERAL ASSISTANCE
RECIPIENTS MANY OF THEM WERE ON
HOUSE. UNFORTUNATELY LAST YEAR'S
GOLDEN STATE STEM THIS GRANT DID
NOT REACH THESE INDIVIDUALS. WHO
ARE REALLY VULNERABLE- AND
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO BE LEFT
OUT OF MANY FORMS REALLY. AS WE
RECOGNIZE THE GRIDLOCK THAT'S
HAPPENING IN DC EVEN ON
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD ASSIST
FAMILIES IN NEED. IT'S REALLY UP
TO THE STATE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SYSTEMS TO. TO MOVE
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF POVERTY
THANK YOU MISTER. CHAIRMAN HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
SANCHEZ- FIVE STAR OPENING THIS
UP FOR THE PANEL AND- AND THIS
IS BEEN CERTAINLY A VERY BIG
TOPIC FOR- FOR IN THE NEWS IN
JUST THE PAST WEEK OR SO AND WAS
ALLUDED TO IN IN THE FIRST PANEL
ABOUT BABY FORMULA. AND WHETHER
FAMILIES THAT ARE ASSISTED BY
OUR FOOD BANKS- HAVE BEEN
SEEKING- MORE ASSISTANCE AND THE
FOOD BANKS HAVE SEEN A CHALLENGE
IN GETTING ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES I'M A FEW YEARS
REMOVED FROM- BUYING BABY
FORMULA SO I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT
THE SHELVES TO SEE THAT
PERSONALLY SO I'D BE GLAD IT
LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT. SURE I CAN I CAN SURE
FIRST AND THEN BACK YOU CAN
SHARE MORE STATEWIDE-
PERSPECTIVE. IN SERVICES GOING
MARIN WE DEFINITELY HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASED DEMAND FOR BABY FOOD
IT ISN'T ACTUALLY A FOOD PRODUCT
THAT WE SOURCE PROACTIVELY. SO
WE TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE ANY- IN
OUR WAREHOUSE UNLESS IT'S BEEN
DONATED TO US AND THEN WE OFTEN-
REDISTRIBUTE TO ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE HOMELESS PRENATAL
PROGRAM. OR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WE KNOW SERVE THAT
POPULATION DIRECTLY. BUT WE HAVE
BEEN HEARING IT QUITE A BIT ON
THE GROUND AT OUR PANTRIES A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE ARE NOW COMING TO
US ASKING FOR IT. SO IT IS
DEFINITELY A HUGE A HUGE DEMAND-
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE- THE
SUPPLY ON HAND TO MEET IT. THANK
YOU MISS DAVISON MISSILE DID YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING TO THEM.
SURE I CAN HANDLE THAT THANK YOU
FOR RAISING THIS QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY IT'S TOP OF MIND FOR.
MANY OF US AND IT REALLY
CRITICAL URGENT REALLY
HEARTBREAKING SITUATION THAT
WE'RE SEEING ALL THE- WE'RE
MONITORING IT AS WELL WE ARE
I'M- IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
HEAR FROM FOOD BANKS ABOUT WHAT
THEIR EXPERIENCES AROUND US AND
I'M GLAD THAT. I'M IS DAVIDSON
WAS ABLE TO ON YOUR FOR EXAMPLE
FRIENDS ARE DISCOVERING LEVINE-
THERE ARE VERY FEW FEW OUT THAT
JUST. BABY FOR I THINK MOSTLY
BECAUSE I YEAR I'M VERY STRICT-
REGULATIONS AND PROTOCOLS
AROUND- YOU KNOW HOW LONG YOU
CAN BE ON THE SHUTTLE AND HOW IT
SHOULD BE STORED AND THINGS
LIKE. THAT WE ARE LEANING ON AND
LEARNING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
WEEK ASSOCIATION IN TERMS OF
OPTIONS THAT WE CAN TAKE AND
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AS A STATE
TECHNICAL MEDIATE THIS PRESSURE-
SO AGAIN JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU RAISING THIS CONCERN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE MONITORING
AS WELL- AND WILL BE. WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO TRY AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ELEVATING
ANY SOLUTIONS THAT WE THANK YOU
GOD. I'M SURE STATE PARTNERS- SO
THAT WE CAN ALL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS SPACE SO
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION YEAH I
THINK I REMEMBER THE BABY
FORMULAS IT C. FEELS QUITE
PRICEY- AND I REMEMBER THAT-
IT'S BEEN YEAH AGAIN A DECADE
PLUS SINCE I HAD. TO BUY IT FOR
MY KIDS BUT- YOU KNOW
NOURISHMENT OF ONE'S CHILDREN IS
JUST A TOP OF MIND FOR ANY
PARENT. YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE FED SUIT SO AN INFANT
CAN SLEEP THROUGH THE NIGHT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FED SO THEY CAN GROW- THEY HAVE
THE PROPER NUTRIENTS FOR THEIR
BRAINS DEVELOPMENT- AND SO TO-
TO NOT BE AWARE TO NOT HAVE US.
OUR TENSION CALL TO THIS IS
POLICYMAKERS- TO IT TO I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE KIND OF LATE IN THE
GAME TO MAKE SURE THAT PARENTS
WHO CARE ABOUT THIS HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO GET. THE
FORMULA. THAT THEIR CHILDREN
NEED- IT- IT'S JUST A- FOR US TO
COMMUNITY AN EYE ON THE SPEAK-
THAT'S A LOT OF FIVE THERE'S A
LOT OF RISK. I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
AT HAT- SO THANK YOU- NO HOW
HAS THE- WITH KIND OF. THE
MULTIPLE CRISES THAT WE HAVE
FACED- THAT THE PANDEMIC AND NOW
THESE INFLATIONARY PRESSURES
BOTH WERE- DIFFERENT IN THE WAY
THAT THEY AFFECTED. THOSE
ABILITY TO GET FOOD BUT A LOT OF
IT WAS FINANCIAL BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE LOWEST INCOME
OFTEN WERE THE ONES MOST
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC AND THE
PANDEMIC RECESSION THAT HIT
THEIR FAMILIES BUT BUT DIDN'T
HIT THE STATE'S BUDGET- BUT YET
THE RESOURCES- MAYBE HAVEN'T
FLOWED. ADEQUATELY TO IT TO
SUSTAIN THE ATTENTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE ON THOSE FAMILIES AS AS
WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO BRING.
EVERYONE ALONG ON ON THAT
RECOVERY- YOU KNOW HOW HOW HAVE
YOU. LEARNED OR ADAPTED TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS OF FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY BOTH INFLATION
AND THE PANDEMIC HOW THEY
CHANGED ARE THEY THE SAME
THROUGHOUT BOTH. I KNOW THE
PANDEMIC'S NOT OVER. AND ANYONE
CAN JUMP IN. I CAN OFFER JUST
KIND OF A BROAD I'M OVERVIEW OF
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING AND HEARING
FROM ALLEN FEEDBACK THE CROSSES
STATE FARRELL. I DO IT I'M BIG
PICTURE I WOULD SEE THAT FEW
BEINGS HAVE. REALLY ADOPTED AND
CHANGED AND SHIFTED THE WAY THAT
THEY OPERATE SO YOU KNOW YOU
BANKS. THROUGH THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC EARLY ON WERE HAVING TO
SCRAMBLE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
OKAY WITH ALL THESE. SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN FOR THE WAY OF THAT
OUR PROGRAMS OPERATE AND YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU PROBABLY SAW IT
IN THE NEWS AND THERE ARE MANY
VIDEO- THINGS DOING DISTRIBUTION
SITES WHERE PEOPLE WOULD DRIVE
UP IN THEIR CAR IN ORDER TO
AVOID. ARE WE- TOO YOU KNOW WE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW YEAH YOU KNOW
SPACE BECAUSE I THAT- WE READ
HEARD A STORY. MUD- BUT I THINK
PARTNER. ABOUT SEEING KEEP. WALK
SO THERE A FEW THREE FIVE AS A
TO DRAW. BECAUSE FAMILIES ARE
TO. THE GAS THE CAR IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO THEIR JOBS- AND SO
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN CONTINUOUSLY
HUMBLED THROUGH THIS ENTIRE
PANDEMIC. AND NOW THROUGH THIS.
INFLATION'S ABOUT HOW YOU BEING
JUST KEEP A YOU KNOW ANY THE
NEXT CHALLENGE THE THRONE AT
THEM THAT THEY THINK OF ANOTHER
WAY TO TRY AND ADOPT AND CHANGE
TO MEET THE SITUATION THAT
THEY'RE IN TODAY SO I KNOW
MAKING SPEECH ABOUT FROM THE
BEGINNING RESPECTIVOS WELL
THAT'S KIND OF AN OVERVIEW. BUT
I WOULD GIVE STATEWIDE. I'M IF
YEAH MISTER SUCH AS GO AHEAD
YOUR HONOR IF I MAY I THINK ONE
THING THAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT-
WHEN IT COMES TO INFRASTRUCTURE
AND DELIVERING OF BENEFITS-
CALIFORNIA DOES NEED TO IMPROVE
OUR- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
SEE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO REALLY
RESPOND DURING THE PAST. HOW DO
WE GET MONEY AND HANDS OUTING A
MILLION HANDS RIGHT AWAY WERE
FORTUNATE WHEN IT CAME TO. TWO
CHILDREN AND SCHOOLS WERE ABLE
TO MOVE VERY SWIFTLY. BUT I
THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT THE STATE.
NEEDS TO REALLY THINK LONG TERM
AS- STE MORE SPECIFIC TO THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY- WHO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WASN'T
NECESSARILY THERE- AND THEN AS
AS A RELATES TO FOLKS WHO ARE OR
ARE. CURRENTLY STILL- THROUGH
GOING TO THE PANDEMIC AND TRENT
TRYING TO RECOVER. I THINK WE
SING WITH IT WITH- SOMETIMES ON
POVERTY. WHEN UNFORTUNATELY OUR
LOVED ONE WHO- WAS THE
BREADWINNER OF THE FAMILY HAVE
PASSED AWAY. I HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT WHERE THE-
THE INDIVIDUALS ARE. YOU KNOW
MAY HAVE NOT WORKED IN THE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS AND ARE BECOMING
THE BREADWINNERS OF THE CHILDREN
OF. OF THE FAMILIES WHO ARE IN
THEIR EARLY TEENS OR EARLY
TWENTIES. ARE ARE NOW BECOMING
THE BREADWINNERS WE KNOW THAT
MORE SPECIFICALLY. FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES IF THERE
WAS ONE PERSON WHO HAD A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. THEY
AUTOMATICALLY BECAME LAW- THE
BREADWINNER AND SALT. THIS
CONTINUES TO BE. A THEME THAT
WE'VE SEEN. FROM AND SO DO WE-
CREATE A SAFETY NET THAT
CAPTURES A- EITHER SEVERAL. AND
I JUST THAT THAT WOULD DO THAT-
INCLUDING A SAFETY NET PROGRAM
AWAITING- PROVIDE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR A
DOCUMENT FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
SANCHEZ- I DON'T WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAUGHT EVERYONE WHO
WANTED TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
QUESTION AND IF WE HAVE. I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU- TO MS SILVA-
TO MISS DAVIDSON MR SANCHEZ AND
MR CHOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PURCHASING THIS PANEL ON IMPACTS
OF INFLATION. ON FOOD SECURITY
ORGANIZATIONS I'M GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR CONTRIBUTION THIS
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING US. THANK YOU YOU ARE
WELCOME THANK YOU AGAIN HI I WE
WILL BRING UP OUR THIRD PANEL.
PANEL THREE. IMPACTS OF
INFLATION ON FOOD GROWERS
PRODUCERS AND WORKERS WE HAVE A
LOT TO SEE A GARCIA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
JIM HOUSTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU- JAZZY GRUEL FROM
THE UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS. AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S HERE VIRTUALLY AND
THAT IS. NICOLE RICE COACH KNOWS
THAT IS- THAT IS THE REPLACE GOT
IT OKAY. THE WHOLE RACES IS
VIRTUALLY HERE GOT IT OKAY SO WE
WILL BEGIN WITH MS GARCIA THANK
YOU HI I'M NOT MYSTERIES. I'M
KELLY ASH I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
WE GOT A COUPLE OF SUBSTITUTION
STATUS UPS IS THE ABSENCE OF THE
TWO SHINS BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR FOR. BRINGING THIS
CONVERSATION TOGETHER WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW-
THE GROCERYINDUSTRY REALLY DOES
CARE ABOUT- OUR COMMUNITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE FED-
AND THERE'S A LOT OF STRAIN
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW. SO I WANTED TO
START WITH JUST SAYING YOU KNOW
ANY KNOWLEDGE IN THAT YOU KNOW
INFLATION IS VERY MUCH UP. I
THINK WE ALL WE ALL KNOW WHY
THAT'S WERE HERE- IN MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. INFLATION
REACH LEVELS SEEN IN FOUR YEARS
- ACROSS ALL CONSUMER CATEGORIES
NOT JUST. THE FOOD SYSTEMS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY-
BUT WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT
INFLATION- YOU KNOW US AT C. G.
A. N. AS GROCERS IN THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY. WE REFERENCE THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS.
PRODUCER PRICE INDEX NOT JUST
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX BECAUSE
THE PRODUCER PRICE INDEX REALLY
TALKS ABOUT. WHAT IT COSTS TO
MAKE AND MOVE GOODS- AND SO AS
YOU KNOW AS A RETAILER THAT'S
WHAT WE LOOK AT- WE REVIEWED THE
MOST RECENT P. P. I. NUMBERS- IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO THEIR DEPARTMENT OF
AGRIBUSINESS- I'M AN OVERALL
THAT PP I INFLATION NUMBER IS
ELEVEN POINT 2% TO GIVE YOU
CONTEXT AROUND THAT- I'M SURE
YOU ALREADY KNOW BUT- THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX IS AT EIGHT
POINT FIVE PERCENT. AS OF MARCH
AND THAT'S THE LATEST NUMBER WE
HAVE ON THAT SO THERE IS A BIG
DISPARITY THERE IN WHAT IT'S
COSTING TO MAKE GOODS AND TO
BRING. PRODUCTS TO MARKET- YOU
KNOW IS I KNOW SOME OTHER FOLKS
OF STE TOUCHED ON EARLIER
ANOTHER PANELS BUT- GAS GAS
PRICES ARE UP WATERS UP ENERGY
INGREDIENTS PACKAGING AND
TRANSPORTATION EVERYTHING. EVERY
STOP ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN IN
ORDER TO GET FOOD TO- A
CALIFORNIA. IS UP. AND SO WHEN
WE'RE OPERATING AS RETAILERS ON
RAZOR THIN MARGINS. YOU KNOW
THOSE COSTS ARE NATURALLY GOING
TO GO UP AND IN FACT SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE EVEN GONE OUT SO
FAR IS TO EAT. SOME OF THESE
INCREASES ON STAPLE ITEMS LIKE
BREAD- MILK AND EGGS. WHICH I
KNOW IT HAS BEEN A BIG
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY AND YEAH
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARTS OF THAT
THAT ARE IN- SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER- BUT A LOT OF THEM ARE.
EATING FRANKLY THOSE THOSE
INCREASES IN COSTS- AND- AND
DOING WHAT THEY CAN FOR
CALIFORNIANS- ACCORDING. TO THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS P. PI
- PRODUCTION INFLATION IS UP
THIRTY ONE POINT 9% ENERGY IS UP
THIRTY FIVE POINT 7% PACKAGING
IS UP 23% PROCESSING IS UP 33%%
AND TRANSPORTATION IS UP TWENTY
POINT 2% SO THESE ARE REALLY
REALLY LARGE NUMBERS IN THE
SPECIFIC SECTORS ANY STOPS ALONG
THE SUPPLY CHAIN- WE HAPPEN TO
BE THE CULMINATION OF WHERE ALL
OF THAT STUFF MEETS. ANDWHERE
THE CONSUMER SEES THE PRICE TAG
. SO WE DO WHAT WE CAN WE
DEFINITELY ARE- INTERVAL PARTS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WANT TO
SERVE THEM- WE'VE BEEN FEELING
IT RIGHT ALONG WITH OUR
CONSUMERS AND OUR YOU KNOW OUR
KIND NEIGHBORS. YOU KNOW
INFLATION THAT WERE SEEN THOUGH
IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO THE FOOD
SYSTEM INDUSTRY- SO AS WERE AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS. YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT REALLY ONE SPECIFIC
THING WE CAN POINT TO AS TO WHY.
SOMETHING MAY BE HIGHER PRICED
OR WHY INFLATION IS UP IN ONE
SPECIFIC SPOT LIKE THE YOU KNOW
PROFESSORS HAS SPOKE TO EARLIER.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS- CULMINATING ALTOGETHER
FOR INSTANCE EGGS AVIAN FLU
HAPPENS TO BE A PIECE OF THAT
PUZZLE. ON THE IMPLICATE- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP TWELVE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR ON
THE A PORTION OF IT AT LEAST.
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THOSE ARE-
ALL LITTLE PIECES THAT PLAY INTO
THE LARGER PUZZLE- YOU KNOW WE
FEEL. WE'RE FEELING THIS
WORLDWIDE AND MULTI INDUSTRY
INFLATION RIGHT ALONG WITH
EVERYONE ELSE- AND WE'VE BEEN
DOING WHAT WE CAN TO MITIGATE
THAT ERE POSSIBLE- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF A LOT OF THE
EFFORTS THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
THE LAST PANEL- IN FACT WE- ARE.
PARTNERING WITH. A COUPLE OF
OTHER GROUPS INCLUDING SPUR. ON
SPONSORING AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. IT LOOKS TO EXPAND
WHAT WAS A PILOT PROGRAM ON
INCREASING- DOLLARS TO. SNAP
PARTICIPANTS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO GET MORE FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES- AND THAT COULD LOOK
LIKE AS MUCH AS SIXTY DOLLARS-
SIXTY TWO DOLLARS A MONTH. AND
THERE'S ALSO APPEARED BUDGET ASK
WITH THAT THAT WE- HAVE BEEN
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO SUPPORT
WHICH IS TO THE TUNE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT WE THINK COULD GO
REALLY LONG WAY TO HELPING
SUPPORT. BOWL IN GETTING- BETTER
ACCESS TO FRESHER FOODS. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS ON
AVERAGE- WE NEXT HAVE- JIM
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU THANK YOU MR LEVINE. KIND
OF FUNNY ANECDOTE I THINK THIS
KIND OF TYPIFIES WHERE WE'RE
STANDING THIS IS DECEMBER- THIS
PAST YEAR. MY MOM IS COMING. UP
AND SHE REALLY LIKES RECS AND
SO- I WAS GONNA MAKE RIBS AND I
YOU KNOW I. SMOKED RIBS YOU KNOW
WITH QUITE FREQUENTLY EITHER
GENERALLY THREE NINETY NINE A
POUND. I WENT TO THE STORE IS
NOT GONNA FLOOR IN IN DECEMBER
AND THEY WERE NINE NINETY NINE A
POUND. AND I WENT TO THE
CHECKER- BECAUSE UNITED HAVE A
DAD SO I YOU KNOW TOLD CORNY DAD
JOKES AND DO THINK SUPER SPY
KIDS AND SO I SAID TO THIS
PERSON IS YOU KNOW. TWENTY OR
WHATEVER I SAID HEY YOU KNOW
I'VE SPENT MY ADULT CAREER
TRYING TO PREVENT THE GOVERNMENT
FROM BREAKING THE FOOD SYSTEM
AND CLEARLY I AFFECT. ITSELF
YARDS IN HOUSTON WITH CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU I AM THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU. AND I HAVE I SPENT
TWENTY TWO YEARS- IN THIS TOWN-
WORKING- IN AG POLICY ABOUT MY
START WITH THIS MONTH SALINAS.
I'VE WORKED I WORKED UNDER JERRY
BROWN AS UNDERSECRETARY CDFA- SO
I HAVE SOME PERSPECTIVE- BUT- AS
AS YOU MAY KNOW I'M SURE YOU
KNOW MR LEVINE- BUT BUT OTHERS
WATCHING MAY NOT CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU. IS COMPRISED OF TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND FARMS AND RANCHES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND 80% OF
THOSE FARMS BY THE WAY OUR SMALL
FARMS. THE BIG EYED AT GFI I'M
IN CALIFORNIA ANOTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. PLUS
ANOTHER EIGHT THOUSAND
SUPPORTING BUSINESSES MANY OF
WHOM YOU HAVE HEARD. ABOUT IT
FROM HERE- ARE THESE BUSINESSES
SPAN FIFTY SIX OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. WE
DO NOT HAVE A FARM BUREAU IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH PROBABLY MAKES
SENSE A LOT OF FARM GROUND
THERE- THAT ALPINE IS BASICALLY-
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO WE
DON'T HAVE A FARM BUREAU THERE
BUT WE DO WE SPAN BASICALLY THE
ENTIRE STATE AND WE EXPAND EVERY
COMMODITY THAT IS GROUND- AND
WE'RE THE ONLY. GROUP THAT THAT
DOES THAT THAT THAT IS THAT BIG.
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS- SO WE STARTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY. AND FOR EACH
AND ONE OF THE EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF THOSE YEARS. FARMERS HAVE
GATHERED FROM AROUND THE STATE
TO DISCUSS THE STATE FARM. AND
TO TALK ABOUT POLICIES THAT
COULD THAT SHOULD GUIDE US- AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAVE BEEN VERY VERY
DIFFICULT- BUT THIS PAST ONE
WAS. ABSOLUTELY THE WORST. AND
INFLATION IS JUST THE LAST AND
MOST PREDICTABLE RESULT OF THE
POLICY CHOICES THAT HAVE PUT US
IN THE PLACE THAT WE ARE TODAY.
I DO NOT GET ME WRONG. I
UNDERSTAND EVERY YEAR WE FACE
ANOTHER CHALLENGES. WHETHER
CLIMATE CHANGE FOUGHT. THIS
DISEASE PANDEMIC. ALMOST
ETCETERA ARE ALL THINGS WE READ
. HALF TO ADAPT. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE FACING
SEEMINGLY UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW. IN THE
MIDST OF AN EPIC DROUGHT. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEN. AND NOW
ON THE POLICY CHOICES WE MAKE.
AND WHETHER WE CHOOSE TO LEARN
FROM THE PAST OR REPEAT. WHILE
THIS MAY BE THE WORST DROUGHT
THE FARM BUREAU HAS EVER
EXPERIENCED IT IS NOT THE FIRST.
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH MULTIPLE
PANDEMICS MULTIPLE WORLD WARS WE
WERE HERE BEFORE THE FREEWAYS
BEFORE THE DANCE BEFORE THE
CANALS BEFORE THE PORTS. WE HAVE
LIVED THROUGH THE FARM CRISIS OF
THE TWENTIES AND THE THIRTIES
THE NINETEEN TWENTIES IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES WE HAVE LIVED
THROUGH THE FARM CRISIS OF THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES. AND EACH ONE
OF THOSE WAS LIKE AN EARTHQUAKE
. THE GROUND SHIFTED. NEVER TO
RETURN AGAIN TO THE WAY IT WAS.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT MOST PEOPLE
I'M FORTY FIVE MOST PEOPLE OF MY
AGE. WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
NO IDEA. THE FARM CRISIS OF THE
EIGHTIES EVEN EXISTED. I ONE OF
THE SPEAKERS MADE REFERENCE TO
THE FACT THAT THIS IS THE
HIGHEST INFLATION THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN FORTY TWO YEARS I DID A
QUICK MATH. TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO GO BACK FORTY TWO
YEARS NINETEEN EIGHTY. SO WE SEE
THE CORRELATION WE SEE THE PETE
THE PATTERN REPEATING. SO I
WOULD POSTULATE THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF ANOTHER LIKE
CRISIS IN FARMING. BUT WHETHER
IT RESULTS IN A SEISMIC SHIFT OR
NOT HAS YET TO BE DETERMINED. WE
HAVE NOT HAD ANY SERIOUS WATER
INVESTMENTS IN THIS STATE FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. DESPITE FUNDS
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND VOTER
WILLINGNESS. NOW ALL THE CUTS
THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE IN URBAN
AND RURAL AREAS ARE DEEPER THAN
THEY NEEDED TO BE. WE CAN'T EVEN
REPAIR THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
HAVE NOW. CENTRE HER TADO HAS
BEEN ON A CRUSADE TO REPAIR
CANAL A CANAL THAT IS ESSENTIAL
TO HER DISTRICTS LIVELIHOOD AND
SHE STILL CAN'T GET THE DESIRED
FUNDS WHICH IS A MERE 1% OF THE
DISCRETIONARY SURPLUS THAT THE
STATE HAS AVAILABLE TO IT. BUT
IT WAS NOT IN THE MAY REVISE.
THERE ARE STILL COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LEFT WANTING. NOW KEEP IN
MIND THAT FARMERS AND
COMMUNITIES STILL PAY FULL
FREIGHT FOR THEIR WATER WHETHER
THEY GET IT OR NOT. IN ADDITION
TO THE WATER SCARCITY AND PRICE
HIKES WE ARE ALSO FACING WHAT
YOU HAVE HEARD TODAY INPUT
PRICES OF 223100% FORTY TWO
RECENT UNIVERSITY OF ILLINOIS
STUDY AMMONIA AND POTASSIUM
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS FOR
FERTILIZER HAVE GONE UP A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE AND A
HUNDRED AND 8% RESPECTIVELY YEAR
OVER YEAR ACROSS THE NATION. BUT
THE NUMBERS THAT I HEAR
CALIFORNIANS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER. FRANCE'S ARE ORGANIC
GROWERS STRUGGLE TO FARID
NITROGEN OF PLACES AND THEY HAVE
TO GET CREATIVE AND THOSE THOSE
OFTEN REPLYING GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAINS AND THOSE ARE GETTING
SQUEEZED. AND THOSE ARE NICHE
PRODUCTS TO THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY SOLD IN THE MIDWEST
. THE SIDES ARE 3100% ABOVE LAST
YEAR IF YOU CAN GET. NOW THE
USDA ESTIMATES THAT 40% OF CROPS
NATIONWIDE ARE LOST DUE TO PESTS
AND DISEASE EVERY YEAR. SO
DEARTH OF THESE TOOLS ONLY
EXACERBATES THE FOOD SUPPLY
ISSUE AND UNDERMINES OUR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION EFFORTS. SO FOR MY
FOR THE TOP FUNGICIDE USED IN
CALIFORNIA I MEAN IT THE OTHERS
MIGHT NOT IT MIGHT AS WELL NOT
EVEN BE CONSIDERED WILL BE 4100%
THAT'S FOUR TIMES WHAT IT WAS
LAST YEAR. FOR ORGANIC GROWERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
BASICALLY THE ONLY FUNGICIDE
THEY HAVE AVAILABLE AND IT'S
GOING TO BE FOUR TIMES WHAT IT
WAS LAST YEAR. DIESEL FUEL IS UP
5275% EMPLOYEE COSTS ARE UP
10215% AND GOING HIGHER. AND TO
MAKE IT ALL WORSE MARKETS ARE
EVAPORATING AS THE GLOBAL SUPPLY
CHAINS BECOME INCREASINGLY
UNAVAILABLE. COME SEPTEMBER WE
WILL BE SHAKING ALMOND TREES BUT
WE STILL HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION
POUNDS SITTING IN WAREHOUSES
WAITING FOR THEIR CUSTOMERS
OVERSEAS ALREADY BEEN PURCHASED.
THEY JUST NEED TO GET A
CONTAINER. NOW IT'S THE REVERSE
IN TOMATOES. NEWS FOR CATCHMENT
SAUCES THEY'RE HOPING THAT THEY
CAN GET ENOUGH FRUIT OFF THE
VINE TO FILL STORE SHELVES COME
JUNE AND JULY. NOW KEEP IN MIND
WE ARE 99% OF THE WORLD'S ON THE
SUPPLY. WE ARE 90% OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPPLY OF PROCESSING
TOMATOES A 60% OF THE WORLD'S
SUPPLY. THIS IS A GLOBAL PROBLEM
. THE BANK OF ENGLAND TESTIFIED
JUST YESTERDAY THE GOVERNOR OF
THE BANK OF ENGLAND TOLD THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON TREASURY
THAT THERE WAS LITTLE THAT THEY
COULD DO TO CONTROL INFLATION
AND THAT MPS SHOULD BE PREPARED
FOR A QUOTE AND A POCKET
LIPSTICK GLOBAL FOOD SUPPLY
SHORTAGE. THE WORLD BANK JUST
TODAY. ANNOUNCED AN ADDITIONAL
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS BRINGING
THE TOTAL UP TO THIRTY BILLION
AVAILABLE TO FIGHT GLOBAL STREET
FOOD SHORTAGES. THE WORLD BANK
PRESIDENT DAVID MALPASS SAID IN
ANNOUNCING THIS TODAY. THAT
QUOTE COUNTRIES SHOULD AKE
CONCERTED EFFORTS TO INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF ENERGY AND
FERTILIZER. HELP FARMERS
INCREASE PLANTINGS AND CROP
YIELDS. NO IT WILL NOT SURPRISE
YOU TO HEAR THAT WE ARE NOT
SEEING THAT FROM THE OTHER THE
LEGISLATURE CALIFORNIA OR THE
ADMINISTRATION. INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT IS
DEBATING THE CHOICE WHETHER TO
USE OUR BILLIONS TO GET FARMERS
OR RANCHERS TO GROW LESS BY
BUYING UP THEIR LAND AND WATER
AND PAYING THEM TO GROW LESS
FOOD. WE'RE USING THOSE BILLIONS
TO BELIEVE THE FARM ECONOMY AND
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO RELY ON
IT. NOW WE COULD CHOOSE TO USE
THOSE BILLIONS TO HELP ON HELP
THESE EMPLOYEES HAVE ALREADY
FORCED REDUCED INCOME TO THE
OVERTIME LAW. I'VE HAD TO WORK
THROUGH A PANDEMIC TO KEEP
EVERYBODY FED AND NOW ARE BEING
LAID OFF DUE TO THE DROUGHT.
JUST LAST WEEK FIFTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE WERE LAID OFF IN RICE
COUNTRY DUE TO NO PLANTINGS AND
NO MAILINGS. WITH NO FOOD COMES
NO PROCESSING NO VALUE ADDED NO
TRUCKS NO SHIPS NO RETAIL SALES
AND NOTHING AVAILABLE FOR FOOD
BANKS YOU CAN GIVE THE FOOD
BANKS ALL THE MONEY IN THE WORLD
TO BUY FOOD BUT THERE NEEDS TO
BE FOOD AVAILABLE TO BE BOUGHT.
ALL OF THOSE ARE LOST JOBS SO IT
IS THE PEOPLE THAT WE WORRY MOST
ABOUT. WE MET AS A BOARD
YESTERDAY HALF OF THIS YEAR HALF
OF US IN DC. AND THAT WAS WHAT
THE DISCUSSION WAS ABOUT. OUR
BOARD IS MADE UP ENTIRELY OF
FARMERS. 101% YOU HAVE TO BE A
FORMER TO BE ON OUR BOARD AND
THAT IS WHAT THEY TALKED ABOUT
THEIR FACING THE RUIN OF THEIR-FARMS. THE END OF HUNDREDS OF
YEARS OF FAMILY FARMING AND THEY
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE THEY'RE OUR NEIGHBORS
THEIR FAMILY THEIR FRIENDS. AND
THEY ARE FACING HARDSHIPS AS YOU
HAVE SEEN. SO. WHETHER PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO RETAIN THEIR JOBS
ARE NOT THERE FACING
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER FOOD PRICES
AS WE'VE HEARD HERE TODAY. SO
THE CHOICE IS. THAT WE FACE
TODAY. OR WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO. NOW IMAGINE IF WE MADE
DIFFERENT CHOICES. IMAGINE IF WE
TOLD THE WATER BOARD AND THE
WATER COMMISSION THAT ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH THE TIME FOR REASONABLE
THIS IMPRACTICALITY ARE AT HAND
. IMAGINE WE ENABLED OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO INVEST IN WATER
STORAGE WE SUPPORTING GROUND
WATER RECHARGE REPAIRED OUR
CANALS AND GAVE REAL RELIEF TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS INSTEAD OF
DRIBBLING IT OUT THROUGH NGO
INTERMEDIARIES. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WHAT MOST ECONOMISTS
ALREADY AGREE ON. THAT THE MOON
ROOF BECAUSE OF INFLATION IS AN
INCREASE IN THE SUPPLY OF MONEY.
SO WE NEED TO STOP BRINGING IT.
NOW I KNOW AS WELL AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO WE ARE LIMITED IN
WHAT WE CAN DO TO CONTROL THE
SUPPLY OF MONEY. BUT THAT DOES
NOT MEAN THAT WE ARE LIMITED IN
WHAT WE CAN DO TO STAVE OFF ITS
IMPACTS. AS A FAMOUS PRAYER
GOES. WE NEED THE SERENITY TO
ACCEPT THE THINGS WE CANNOT
CHANGE. THE COURAGE TO CHANGE
THE THINGS WE CAN. WE CAN CHOOSE
TO MAKE RELIEF AVAILABLE TO
FARMERS DIRECTLY AND EASILY WE
CAN CHOOSE TO PROVIDE A TAX
CREDIT THAT WILL HELP EMPLOYERS
AFFORD OVERTIME AGAIN PLEASE
MORE MONEY. WE CAN CHOOSE TO
SUPPORT MORE DAMS STORAGE CAN
VANCE ON FARM PONDS WATER
RECYCLING GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
AND SHORING UP OUR WATER RIGHTS
SYSTEM INSTEAD OF ERODING IT. WE
CAN SUPPORT THE FARM COMMUNITIES
BUT YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE. WERE
LIVING IT AND WHO THANKFULLY
HAVE BEEN THROUGH IT BEFORE AND
HAVE A TRACK RECORD ON WORKING
HARD TOWARDS SUCCESS. WE'VE BEEN
HERE FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
AND HOPED TO BE HERE FOR A
HUNDRED MORE. BUT WE HAVE TO
WORK TOGETHER. LEARN FROM THE
PAST AND HAVE THE COURAGE TO
MAKE HARD CHOICES NOW. FOR A
BETTER FUTURE. I WILL AND WAS
SAYING MR LEVINE YOU HAVE
DEMONSTRATED GREAT COURAGE AND
YOUR TIME HERE AND LEGISLATURE
SO GOD BLESS YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU JIM HOUSTON. HAVE THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS. YEAH I THINK YOU'RE A
MUCH DISTRIBUTION YOU DID NOT
HOLD ANYTHING BACK YOU YOU'VE-
TOLD US EVERYTHING YOU WANTED US
TO KNOW SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OUR NEXT PANELIST IS NICOLE RICE
OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS MS RICE. CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK WE CAN. WONDERFUL
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOLKS
FOR THE UNITS TOGETHER AND
INVITING ME MY NAME IS NICOLE
TRUJILLO RICE AND THAT POLITICAL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
UNITED FOOD COMMERCIAL WORKERS A
LOCALLY WE REPRESENT WORKERS
FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO THE
GREAT FINE WITHIN THE RETAIL
GROCERY FOOD PROCESSING WILL
TELL ME WHY IN PROCESSING OF
LEGALIZED CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND
ALSO PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS. IN THE RETAIL
SECTOR. AND DIE EIGHT I THINK
THAT WHAT MY FELLOW PANELISTS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT TERMS OF
WORKERS FEELING- THE BRUNT OF A
LOT OF THIS IS VERY MUCH TRUE IN
IN IN THAT WE ARE IN AGREEMENT
ON AND YOU KNOW GROCERY WORKERS
OF ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIAL OF THE
PANDEMIC TRULY BROUGHT TO LIGHT
HOW CRITICAL THEY ARE FOR THE
SURVIVAL OF OUR COMMUNITIES-
EVEN THOUGH THE WORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL. TO MANY OF OUR UFCW
MEMBERSHIP. STILL CAN'T AFFORD
TO BUY FOOD FROM THE GROCERY
STORE THEY WORK AT WE KNOW
CUSTOMERS ARE FEELING THE PINCH
OF GROCERY PRICES WE ARE AT THE
CHECK STAND AT THE DELI COUNTER
EVERY DAY- THERE'S A CUMULATIVE
INCREASE AND ALL OF OUR BASIC
HOUSING PRICES GAS PRICES CHILD
CARE MEDICINE. OUR WORKERS ARE
SUFFOCATING FROM THEIR COST OF
LIVING THE REYES IS ACTUALLY
THAT THEY JUST RECEIVED SOME OF
THEM IN THAT NEWLY RATIFIED
CONTRACTS FOR THAT EMPLOYERS
THAT WE REPRESENT. THE EXTRA
MONEY. THAT THEY HAVE. THE OLD
THEY'LL NEED JUST TO GO FOR A
GALLON OF GAS OR A GALLON OF
MILK AND WHAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED IS FOR WAGES TO KEEP UP
WITH THE COST OF LIVING. AND WE
REALLY STEP BACK AND START TO
EXAMINE. HOW WE GOT HERE AND WHY
WE GOT HERE. THERE ARE NUMBER OF
RED FLAGS FOR US THAT REPRESENT
WORKERS. IN ORGANIZED LABOR. THE
FIRST QUESTION THAT WE'VE BEEN
ASKING OURSELVES AND OTHERS
POLICYMAKERS THAT ARE THE
SKYROCKETING PRICES THE RESULT
OF INFLATION OR PRICE GOUGING. I
HAVE TO SERIOUSLY QUESTION
THAT'S WHEN I SEE RETAIL STORES
REPORTING ROCK RECORD PROFITS
WHILE THE PEOPLE THAT SHOP AND
WORK IN THEIR STORES ARE BARELY
MAKING ENDS MEET. A RECENT
ANALYSIS DONE BY THE ECONOMIC
POLICY INSTITUTE FROM DATA
COLLECTED BY THE NATIONAL INCOME
AND PRODUCT ACCOUNTS SHOW THAT
OVER HALF. OF PRICE INFLATION
SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY AS
COME FROM FATTER PROFIT MARGINS
. LABOR COSTS MEANWHILE
ACCOUNTED FOR LESS THAN 8% THIS
IS FAR BIGGER THAN ANY
CONTRIBUTION OF FAST WAGE GROWTH
. THIS RISE IN PROFITS AS A LOT
ABOUT THE INFLATION OF THE PAST
YEAR FOR ONE IT REMINDS US THAT
ONE PERSON'S COST IS ANOTHER'S
INCOME. AND AS A STATE AND AS A
NATION THE MECHANICAL EFFECTS OF
INFLATION JUST DON'T MAKE US
POOR. HIGHER PRICES IN A GIVEN
SECTOR MEAN HIGHER POTENTIAL
INCOMES FOR CAPITAL OWNERS AND
WORKERS IN THAT SECTOR. HOWEVER
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH THE
CURRENT RECOVERY IS THAT THE
HIGHER REVENUE GENERATED BY
HIGHER PRICES. AS OVERWHELMINGLY
GUNS TO THE CAPITAL OWNERS AND
NOT THE WORKERS. THE MOST
IMPORTANT ANGLES OF INFLATION
ARE DISTRIBUTIONAL SELL ASKING
WHY CORPORATE PROFITS ARE
SPIKING WHILE INFLATION ADJUSTED
WAGES ARE FALLING. IS AMONG THE
BIGGEST QUESTION WE NEED TO BE
ASKING RIGHT NOW. AND THE
NARRATIVE THAT CORPORATIONS ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR PROFITS AND
ANY ATTEMPT TO NORMALIZE THIS IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THE NOTION OF
SUCH SHOULD. NEVER ATTRACT THE
ATTENTION OF POLICYMAKERS JUST
SEEMS WRONG TO ME. ANOTHER
SIMPLE MATTER OF FACT THE RISE
IN PROFITS HAS BEEN HISTORIC AND
HAS EXPLAINED FAR FAR MORE OF
THE RISE IN PRICES OVER THE PAST
YEAR THEN LABOR COSTS OR IMPORT
TARIFFS. SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE
TO EXAMINE AND TALK ABOUT- COME
MADE IN AMERICA CAN REDUCE SOME
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES. THE
pUNITED COMMERCIAL WORKERS
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL
REPRESENTING NINE UFCW LOCALS IN
CALIFORNIA ARIZONA AND NEVADA
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
OH EIGHT WHICH THE COPIER- BELL.
AND IT WOULD PROTECT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS BY AND IMPROVE THE
QUALITY AND SAFETY OF SCHOOL
MEALS BY CLARIFYING AND
STRENGTHENING AND BUY AMERICAN
POLICIES- THE UNIONS THAT ARE
UFCW THE TEAMSTERS REPRESENT
WORKERS AND FOOD IN THE FOOD
PROCESSING SPACE AND CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
DIFFERENT AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES OVER ONE THIRD OF
THE COUNTRY'S VEGETABLES AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY THREE THE
NUTS OVER 99% OF CALIFORNIANS
TWELVE HUNDRED DAIRY FARMS ARE
FAMILY OWNED AND THE DAIRY
SECTOR SECTOR SUPPORT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND JOBS. OVER FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
RATHER PEOPLE WORKING
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY FROM FARMWORKERS TO
WORKERS AND FOOD PROCESSING AND
CANNERIES. UNION JOBS IN CARRIES
AND FRUIT PROCESSING AMONG
OTHERS PROVIDE GOOD WAGES
BENEFITS AND RETIREMENT SECURITY
. VETERANS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS BUT UNDER CURRENT USDA
REGULATIONS SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
BYPASS THE EXISTING BUY AMERICAN
REQUIREMENTS AND PURCHASE
PRODUCTS IMPORTED FROM OUTSIDE
THE UNITED STATES IF THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT COST DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN DOMESTIC AND IMPORTED
FOOD PRODUCTS. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS PURCHASE LOWER QUALITY
GOODS BROWN AND PRODUCED OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNTRY UNDER LESS
STRINGENT WORKER HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS DESPITE
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS IN THE
WORLD IT ALSO HAS A STRONG
BELIEVER STANDARDS THAT PROTECT
WORKERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. B. AG INDUSTRY IS
FELT THE IMPACT OF OVERSEAS
COMPETITION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SENECA FOODS A PRODUCER OF PGM
FRUIT COCKTAIL PRODUCTS. CHEN
IT'S MODESTO PLANTS LAYING OFF
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE. FULL
TIME WORKERS AND NEARLY A
THOUSAND SEASONAL WORKERS THE
COMPANY CITED IMPORTANT
COMPETITION FROM OVERSEAS CHINA
AND EUROPE AND THE REASON FOR
THE PLANT CLOSURE. BUY AMERICA
PROVISIONS ARE GOOD FOR WORKERS
PRODUCERS STUDENTS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THIS TIME WE'RE
LIVING IN. WE CAN HELP REDUCE
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES ALONG WITH
OVERSEAS COMPETITION. AND I
THINK JUST TO WRAP IT UP I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THIS BODY THOSE TWO
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS LOOKING AT
. INFLATION FIRST PRICE GOUGING
AS WELL AS LEANING AGAINST YOU-
THE BROADER DIALOGUE THAT WE'RE
HAVING AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
AROUND BY AMERICAN AND BUILD
BACK BETTER. THANK YOU I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR HERE RICE-
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S PANEL- THERE'S A LOT
TO COVER- IN THE- LAST FEW
MINUTES THAT WE HAVE- THIS ROOM
FOR WE DO RENTAL BY THE HOUR
BUT- I TO WANT TO BRING US BACK
TO THE BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE
AND- CERTAINLY FOR GROCERS- WE
DID SEE. FOURTEEN AND SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES IN IN THE PANDEMIC
WHERE WE DID HAVE TO. PUT IN
PLACE WE DIDN'T TAKE GROCERS DID
PUT INTO PLACE SOME TYPE OF-
IT'S TERRIBLE CAUGHT RATIONING
IT MAKES US FEEL LIKE WE'RE YOU
KNOW. IN BEHIND THE- IRON
CURTAIN- BUT- SOMETIMES A LIMIT
ON HOW MUCH PEOPLE CAN BUY OF
CERTAIN PRODUCTS HAVE WE SEEN
THE INSTITUTE HERE FOR BABY
FORMULA. YOU KNOW I CAN'T SPEAK
TO EXACTLY WHAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
COMPANY IS DOING ON THAT- AND
WHAT YOU KNOW EACH INDIVIDUAL
RETAILERS DOING ON THAT
SPECIFICALLY. HOWEVER YOU KNOW
WE ARE SEEING VERY MUCH THE
SHORTAGE OF SUPPLY OUR OUR
MEMBERS ARE GETTING. THE ORDERS
FOR FILTERS THAT THEY'VE PLACED-
OUR- FIRST MOST SIGNIFICANT
PRIORITY- IN WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HERE
IN CALIFORNIAWHO BY THE WAY
HAVE BEEN. PHENOMENAL AND
HELPING US NAVIGATE THIS ISSUE-
IS MAKING SURE FIRST ND
FOREMOST THAT WAKE PARTICIPANTS-
ARE ABLE TO BE ABLE TO BE
SERVICED AND HELPS AND THEY'RE
GETTING THE PROPER FORMULA THAT
THEY NEED- THERE'S ALSO A BIG
CONCERN AROUND- THE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FORMULAS. YOU KNOW I
THINK AND I'M GOING TO GUESS
HERE A LITTLE BIT THAT MAYBE
WITH THE LACK OF REGULAR
FORMULA- BEING AS AVAILABLE AS
IT HAS BEEN IN THE PAST OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WOULD MAYBE BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THAT MIGHT BE GOING
TOWARD- UTILIZING THE ONES THAT
ARE TYPICALLY MORE IT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY THAT AREN'T BEHIND-
THE COUNTER. VIA A PRESCRIPTION.
SO WE'RE SEEING SOME CONCERNS
AND ISSUES THERE- I YOU KNOW WE
WORK REALLY WELL WITH OUR
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS IN DC- WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE USDA-
ON NAVIGATING THESE ISSUES- YOU
KNOW WE GOT AN UPDATE ACTUALLY
WHILE I WAS- YOU KNOW WALKING IN
HERE EARLIER TODAY- YOU KNOW
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT AND
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO RESUME- AN
OPEN REOPEN THAT. PLANT IN
MICHIGAN- IN ABOUT TWO WEEKS AND
RESUME PRODUCTION FOLLOWING ON
THE FDA APPROVAL. OF THEIR OF
THEIR RE OPENING- AND THEN WILL
BE ABLE TO SEE- THAT FORMULA HIT
STORE SHELVES IN ABOUT SIX TO
EIGHT WEEKS. I'M SO THAT'S OUR
BEST ESTIMATE YOU KNOW WE'RE
REALLY JUST- WORKING ON HELPING
OUR MEMBERS MAKE SURE THAT- THEY
HAVE A CONNECTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
VERY CLOSE CONNECTION TO BE ABLE
TO- FACILITATE- AND SUPPORT THEM
IN GETTING THE SUPPLIES THAT
THEY NEED FOR. YOU KNOW FOR
THEIR CUSTOMERS AND WHAT PEOPLE
ARE NEED ESPECIALLY THOSE ON THE
WICK PROGRAM- IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE TO US- I WILL I
WILL SAY THAT. WE THEY'RE
WORKING VERY HARD ON THAT. I
HAVEN'T SEEN TOO MANY PUT IN-
CAPS AND STUFF BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GET TO SOMETHING SO.
PERSONAL SOMETHING SO VERY
NECESSARY. NEED OFTENTIMES
FORMULA IS THE ONLY FOOD SOURCE
FOR A BABY- THEY DON'T WANT TO
LIMIT AND CAP INDIVIDUALS- IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY NEED FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. WE DID WE DD
SEE THAT IN A DIVERSE BUT VERY
SPECIFIC THIS BABY FORMULA
SHORTAGE WHICH HAS HAD THIS
ENTIRE COUNTRY FOR NUMEROUS
DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT WE SAW.
BEHAVIOR DRIVING THESE CONCERNS
AND THE PANDEMIC BUT NOW WE
HAVE. AN INFLATION A SITUATION
AND THE SPECIFIC SHORTAGE ISSUE.
DOES THE INDUSTRY SEE OTHER
INFLATION SHORTAGE-
COMBINATIONS- IT HISTORICALLY
OR- IS THIS JUST UNIQUE IN THE
SENSE INSTANCE. WELL I THINK YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT THE PROFESSOR
SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT- EGGS AND
THE ISSUE THERE THAT WERE SEEN
WITH AVIAN FLU IMPACTING- EGG
PRICES AND THEN ALSO INFLATION.
YOU KNOW- I THINKTHAT'S ANOTHER
PRETTY RELEVANT CURRENT EXAMPLE
. OKAY YEAH I THINK YOU'LL- OKAY
SO WE DID HERE- FROM THIS TRUTH
YOUR RICE ABOUT WORKERS AND-
INCOME AND HOW INFLATION ISN'T
HELPING THEM. WITH THE COST OF
LIVING IN- AT ALL- AND IT'S AN
INTERESTING POINT WE'VE WE LET
OUR ECONOMISTS ARE NOT WITH US
ANY LONGER- BUT YOU KNOW HOW HOW
IS THAT AFFECTED THEM IS THERE
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THERE'S OF COURSE PEOPLE.
PUSH OUT THAT RISING WAGES
DRIVES INFLATION- BUT YET YOU
KNOW IT'S SAD NOT TO USE THE AG
METAPHOR TOO OFTEN A CHICKEN OR
THE EGG HERE YOU KNOW HOW TO
PEOPLE FOR TO LIVE I'M IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT. WE JUST
WANNA KEEP UP. ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THAT IS THE QUESTION. OF
OUR WORKERS THAT WE REPRESENT
FORTUNATELY DO YOU HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
WHERE THEY HAVE RECEIVED- SOME
RACES RECENTLY THEY ASO HAVE A
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION PLAN.
THE EMPLOYERS PAY INTO- AS WELL
AS- A PORTABLE HEALTHCARE. THEIR
WAGES HAVEN'T GONE UP ESPECIALLY
IN THE OTHER ARM THE SAME SECTOR
BUT THE NON UNION. STORES SO
THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT WE
HAVE USUALLY INFLATION INDICATES
RAISING WAGES AS WELL RIGHT WE
JUST HAVEN'T RISEN. WE HAVEN'T
SEEN. A SHIFT TOWARD BEING ABLE
TO AFFORD THESE GOODS AND- IT'S
NOT JUST GROCERIES THAT'S THE
EXAM THAT WE'RE GIVING BECAUSE
OF THOSE THE WORKERS THAT WE
REPRESENT IN FOOD PROCESSING
THEIR EVERYDAY NEEDS. OUR
WORKERS DIDN'T GET TO WORK FROM
HOME THEY SHOWED UP EVERY DAY ON
THE FRONT LINE. SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT GAS CHILD CARE.
ALL OF THESE RAISING HOUSING
PRICES ARE BEING SQUEEZED OUT OF
EVERY MARKET. AND WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY WHERE WE CAN.
ALSO INCREASE THEIR WAGES DO YOU
TO COMPETE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THE CHILD CARE ISSUE
WE JUST ON THE- SOUTH SIDE OF
THE CAPITOL HAVE CHILD CARE
WORKERS WHO ARE RALLYING TODAY-
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALSO FEELING
LEFT BEHIND- IN THIS- ECONOMIC
SITUATION WE ALL FIND OURSELVES
AND- DISTRIBUTION YOU TALKED
ABOUT TOMATOES AND CATCH UP
WHICH IS SOMETHING A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT A LOT
OF STAPLES. PEOPLE REALLY SEEM
TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT EVERYONE HAS. ONE OF THE
ECONOMY ECONOMIST EARLIER TALK
ABOUT PAPRIKA THAT SEEMS A
LITTLE BIT MORE- ARE LESS
EXISTENTIAL BENT AND CATCH UP
DOES- FOR- MOST MOST PEOPLE-
TOMATOES ARE- AS YOU MENTIONED.
90% OF WE'RE YEAH WE'RE 90% OF
THE UNITED STATES SUPPLY
PROCESSING TOMATOES SO IS THERE
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW MAYBE THIS IS A BIG
GROCERS CAN CAN GIVE A
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS. WE IN
CALIFORNIA- YOU MAY AGREE WITH
US- TAKE OUR AGRICULTURE FOR
GRANTED. IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
THERE- WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO
HAVE KETCHUP OR SALSA OR
WHATEVER THAT COMMENT IS THAT WE
LIKE TO THIS TOMATO BASED- AND-
AND SO- WHAT TYPE OF FEEDBACK.
ARE YOU YOUR ORGANIZATIONS
GETTING FROM. YOU KNOW OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA AS TO ALL OF YOUR
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S WATER
POLICY OR AGRICULTURAL POLICY OR
EVEN LABOR POLICY LIKE WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA DOING THAT'S PUTTING-
STAPLES THAT WE ALL DEPEND UPON.
SOMEWHERE ELSE AT RISK BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S- WORKING AGAINST-
YOU KNOW THE PRODUCTION OF THESE
THINGS. YEAH I MEAN THAT'S A
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION-
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY ENOUGH MISTER
REAVIS- WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
HEARING TOMORROW- THEY GOT
POSTPONED AND I WAS GONNA TALK.
ABOUT THAT THAT SORT OF VERY
ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE
COMPETITIVENESS- AND I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW I'M I MEAN ALL
DUE RESPECT BUT AS I WAS
LISTENING TO THE HEARING I MEAN
EVERYBODY JUST ASSUMED THE FOOD
WOULD BE THERE. YOU KNOW THEY
NEED MORE MONEY TO BUY IT THAT
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE THERE RIGHT
NOBODY NOBODY TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
NEED TO HELP OUR FRMERS GROW
MORE FOOD- AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY RIGHT- AND SO BECAUSE
EVERYBODY JUST ASSUMES THAT THAT
THAT WILL HAPPEN- BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT THE CASE AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE GLOBAL FOOD
SUPPLY GLOBAL HUNGER- ALL THOSE-
INDICES ARE. ARE RISING YOU
HEARD THE FOOD BAK PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE FREE TO
IS SECURE AND ALL THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE COMPETITIVENESS OF OUR-
FARMERS AND RANCHERS BECAUSE
THEY ARE COMPETING AGAINST
PEOPLE IN. THE- AND I MEAN.
THANK GOD BLESS ALL THE PEOPLE
IN THE OTHER COUNTRIES ARE GROW
FOOD I MEAN THEY'RE TRYING TO
MAKE A LIVING TO YOU NOW- BUT-
THE FACT IS THAT WE HAVE CERTAIN
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE HELD OUR
GROWERS TO HEAR AND WHETHER THAT
BE- THE OTHER TO THE PRICE OF
JUST HIRING SOMEBODY IS. MORE
THAN DOUBLE HERE THAT IN THE
FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE OF SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE I'M NOT. IN ANY WAY
ADVOCATE OF THE PEOPLE SHOULD
MAKE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WHAT I'M
SAYING LIKE HERE CALIFORNIA
WE'RE DOUBLE THAT YOU KNOW AND
WHEN THE CALMEST ABOUT HE TALK
ABOUT WAGES IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DOLLARS AND IN REALITY THAT IS.
THAT'S THE FUNNY THING ABOUT
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND ABOUT
AGRICULTURE AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NATIONAL STATISTICS ABOUT
WAGES- MINIMUM WAGE WE HAVE ONE
OF THE LOWEST PERCENTAGES OF
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE MAKING- OF
THE- ADAM BELOW MINIMUM WAGE
WHEN YOU COMPARE IT TO OTHER-
YOU KNOW RETAIL- CONSTRUCTION
MINING TRANSPORTATION OTHERS-
ALWAYS COMPLIANCES. IS SIMILARLY
THROUGH THE ROOF SO BECAUSE WE%
CARE BUT WE ALSO WE- WHAT WE
HAVE OVERTIME AFTER FORTY HOURS
NO ONE ELSE DOES- WE HAVE. WE
HAVE CAL SAVERS RIGHT NOW SO
FARM HERE HAS- FOR ONE K- THAT
WE OFFER TO A FORMER POLICE.
WHICH IS HONESTLY A BETTER DEAL
CALCIUM- WE BUT WE- AT LEAST WE
HAVE THAT. RIGHT WE HAVE HIGHER
WATER COSTS HERE SO WE HAVE THE
WATER RIGHTS FEES ARE JUST OUT
OF CONTROL RIGHT OF THE GO OF
EVERY EVERY YEAR- WELL THE-
AMOUNT OF PESTICIDES THAT WERE.
ABLE TO USE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE IT. NOW I LIKE THE I
MEAN DEEP THERE'S A GREAT SYSTEM
AND WE'RE ALL BETTER OFF FOR IT.
RIGHT BUT THAT SYSTEM IS EACH
COST MORE TO IMPLEMENT- AND
THERE. I THINK OKAY. INSTEAD OF
CELEBRATING DVR. WHAT I MEAN
THEIR PLACE TO- YOU KNOW HEY YOU
KNOW IF HE BROKE A FIX IT BUT
THEY'RE POISED TO MAKE THE- YARD
MORE EXPENSIVE MAKE PESTICIDES
LESS AVAILABLE MORE EXPENSIVE-
YOU KNOW SAME THING WITH
FERTILIZERS. AND SO ALL OF THESE
INPUT COSTS. ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN THEY ARE- IT. TO OUR
COMPETITORS- AND SO THE SIMPLE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS- YOU KNOW
GROSS HERE. WE ALSO. HAVE- YEAH
MORE. I KNOW WELL WE HAVE A LOT
OF WELL CAPITALIZED- FOLKS THAT
AR ABLE TO COME IN. AND BUY YOU
KNOW SORT OF SECURITIZE ACLAND
WHICH IS VERY CONCERNED AND YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW HARVARD GROWS A
LOT ALMONDS HERE. YOU KNOW- AND
SO THAT- MAKES SORT OF I MEAN
FOR LACK OF A RESERVE THE NORMAL
FARMER RIGHT LIKE IF I JUST
WANTED TO GO AND INTO FARMING I
NOW HAVE TO COMPETE AGAINST
THESE VERY VERY WELL
CAPITALIZED. ENTITIES IN OUR
STATE SO THERE'S BOTH YOU KNOW
SORT OF OUTSIDE MONEY COMING
INTO THE STATE PUSHING OUT
CALIFORNIA FOLKS- BUT ALSO
CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND RANCHERS
ARE NOT COMPETITIVE AGAINST
THEIR OUT OF STATE AND OUT OF-
COUNTRY COUNTERPARTS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO. MEET ALL OF THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS- THE WE DO CLOSE
FOR AG BY THE WAY I DIDN'T
MENTION THAT MY GOSH WE DO CLOSE
MORE ACCURATE YOU KNOW I MEAN
UNDER FORMAL PRETENSES FOR TEN
YEARS. BUT YOU KNOW WHEN IN
REALITY FOR TWENTY THIRTY YEARS-
WE'RE THE ONLY STATE THAT DOES
IT. YOU KNOW- AND SO IT'S ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT I THAT THAT
YOU KNOW LIKE WHEN WE THINK OF
CALIFORNIA ACT IT MAKES US
PROUD- AND THAT'S WHY WE GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE WE GO TO THE
FARMER I'M OUT ONE THE MOST
EXCITING THINGS THAT HAPPENED TO
ME. IN THE PAST MONTH IS WE GOT
A FARMERS MARKET AT THE ELKS
LODGE ON SATURDAYS AND NOW I GET
TO RIDE MY BIKE TO THE FARMERS
MARKET WITH MY KIDS IT'S THE
IT'S THE COOLEST THING. WE TAKE
THAT FOR GRANTED. OUR WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MYSTERY SO I SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
PANELISTS FOR OUR THIRD PANEL.
IMPACTS OF INFLATION ON FOOD
GROWERS PRODUCERS AND WORKERS.
THAT'S MISS. KELLY ASH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
MR JIM HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. AND IS
ICOLE TRUJILLO RICE. FROM
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ALL
THREE OF YOU. AND WE NOW THE
LAST WORD GOES TO THE PUBLIC. SO
IF PUBLIC COMMENT. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC. TO
COME. AND AND- SHARE YOUR
REMARKS. WITH A GROUP OF. THE
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC I'M
REPRESENTING THE PUBLIC ACTUALLY
GREG GARNER ON BEHALF OF THE CAN
MANUFACTURERS INSTITUTE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE THING WE
WOULD WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING THIS- THE YOU'VE HAD SOME
GREAT PANELS AND RAISE A LOT OF
GOOD ISSUES- WE WANT TO RAISE
SOME ISSUES SPECIFIC TO- OTHER
THINGS THAT'S CREATING THAT'S
GONNA CONTRIBUTE TO FOOD AND
SECURITY IN THE COMING YEAR AS
EARLY AS THIS YEAR DEFINITELY BY
NEXT YEAR THAT'S RELATED TO
TERRACE AND QUOTAS. FOR TEN
PLATE. AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA IS
A BIG CANNING STATE FOR OUR
FOOD- THE CAN MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY DOES OVER TWENTY TWO
AND A HALF BILLION FOOD CANS
PURGE. YEAR AND SHIPMENTS GREW
ABOUT TWELVE POINT 8% DURING THE
PANDEMIC- BUT WE ARE HAVING I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T ENTER WILL RUN
FROM THE SWING SPACE SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ME GETTING MY
WORK OUT TODAY. WE'RE LIVING IN
WE'RE LIVING IT BUT THE YOU KNOW
THE FIRST DAYS IN THE NINETIES
THERE ARE TOUGH- THERE'S BEEN A
STEEP DECLINE IN DOMESTIC TEN
PLATE PRODUCTION. PLUS THE
TARIFFS AND QUOTAS ON IMPORTED
TEMPLATE ARE CREATING A NATIONAL
FOOD SECURITY CRISIS. ONLY 2% OF
DOMESTIC STEEL PER PRODUCED IS
TEN PLATE. ONLY EIGHT TEMPLATE
LINE'S EXISTING US TODAY DOWN
FROM ELEVEN. LINES BEFORE
TARIFFS WERE IMPOSED ONE OF
THOSE IS SCHEDULED TO CLOSE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
DOMESTIC SOURCES WILL BE BELOW
50% DATA FROM BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SHOWS THAT 83% OF OUR
COUNTRY'S KITCHENS HAVE CANNED
FOOD IN THEIR PANTRIES AND THANK
YOU. WE BELIEVE THIS HAS. CREASE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THESE HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE PRODUCTS ARE
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR LOW
INCOME AMERICANS AND U. S. FOOD
BANKS AND THAT'S WHY I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THEM ON-
AMERICANS CONSUME ON AVERAGE
FIVE CANS OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES PER WEEK. BUT
RECIPIENTS OF SNAP AND WEBER
CONSUME SEVEN POINT ONE CANCER
FREAKS IN VEGETABLES. 25% OF THE
FRUIT CONSUMED AN AVERAGE
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS ARE CAN'T.
32% FOR SNAP AND WHAT HOUSEHOLDS
. JUST UNDER ONE THIRD OF
VEGETABLES FOR THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD 39% OF SNACKS
AND WITH HOUSEHOLDS. AN 56% OF
THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD WILL CALL
AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD THINK THAT
CANNED FOOD IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR THEIR NUTRITION
FOR THEIR FAMILY 67% OF SNACKS
AND WITH RECIPIENTS I BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE HEALTH. OF THEIR FAMILY. THE
MINUTES GIPSON I KNOW YOU'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME BUT- IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT LIMITED STEEL
SUPPLY WILL RESULT IN SOME CROP
AND FOOD PRODUCTS NOT BEING
CAN'T. REPEAT WE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL THAT WE WILL HAVE
CROPS THAT WON'T BE CAN'T THESE
ARE CROPS THAT. THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE SOLD IN OTHER MARKETS
THE GROUND GROWN SPECIFICALLY
FOR CANNING THEY WILL BE TOLD
UNDER OR NOT ACCEPTED BECAUSE
WILL RUN OUT OF SUPPLIES IN
ORDER TO CAN THEM. SO WITH
IMPORTS OF CANNED PRODUCTS UP
SUBSTANTIALLY IN TWENTY TWENTY.
BECAUSE OF OUR TARIFFS WHEN WE
HAVE- BASICALLY 40% OF THE COST
OF A CANNED PRODUCT IS THE COST
OF THE CAN. 80% OF THAT NOW IS A
TERROR OF COST. SO AS YOU CAN
SEE CHINA IS ACTUALLY AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE ABLE TO IMPORT.
PRODUCTS FREE. TO WHERE WE HAVE
OUR CONSUMERS AND SCHOOLS BUYING
FOREIGN PRODUCTS RATHER THAN
THOSE PRODUCTS GROWN RIGHT HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IS A
SERIOUS SERIOUS- FOOD SECURITY
ISSUE YEAH WE DID HEAR CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT FROM ONE OF THE LAST
PANELISTS OKAY YEAH WELL. WE
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND WE'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS
ISSUE YEAH I THINK YOU'RE MUCH
MISTER TURNER- THANK YOU THAT
WILL BE THE END OF- PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEN THAT WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE LINE- I FIRST SAW
IT- THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PANEL PARTICIPANTS I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
FROM EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
THANK YOU OF COURSE MY STAFF WHO
HELPED ORGANIZE THIS- WE HAD
BEEN PLANNING THIS FOR- FOR
SOMETIME IN IT I'M GLAD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- AND THE SPEAKER OF
ALLOWED US TO. DO AN AIRING OF
THESE ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN SEE
HOW INFLATION IS IMPACTING
CALIFORNIANS. A NUTRITION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND IT IS
AT RISK WHEN PEOPLE CANNOT
AFFORD- HEALTHY. FRUITS
VEGETABLES AND OTHER GROCERIES.
SO THANK YOU THAT IS THE END OF
OUR HEARING. THANKS TERRY WHAT.
THANK YOU. FOUR PEOPLE HAVE.